the following is a conversation with
sagar anjeri
he is a dc based political correspondent
host
of the rising with crystal ball and host
of the
realignment podcast with marshall kozlov
he has interviewed donald trump four
times
and has interviewed a lot of major
political figures
and human beings who wield power
he loves policy and loves history which
makes him a great person to sail
through the sometimes stormy waters of
political discourse
he showed up to this conversation with a
gift of the second volume of ian
kershaw's biography on hitler
a two-volume set that is widely
acknowledged as one of the greatest
if not the greatest most definitive
studies
of hitler nothing wins my heart faster
on a first meeting or first date than a
grade book about the darkest aspects of
human nature
in human history i think i started
saying that as a joke
but actually there's probably a lot of
truth to it i love it when we skip the
small talk and go straight to the
in-depth conversation about the best and
worst of human nature
quick mention of our sponsors jordan
harbinger show
grammarly grammar assistant eight sleep
self cooling bed
and magic spoon low carb cereal click
the
sponsor links to get a discount and to
support this podcast
as a side note let me say that for
better for worse
i would like to avoid the trap of
surface political bickering of the day
i do find politics fascinating but not
the talking points produced by the
industrial engagement complex of red
versus blue division
instead i'm fascinated by human beings
who seek power
and how power changes them i don't have
a political affiliation
and my ideas at least i hope so are
defined more by curiosity
and learning in the face of uncertainty
and less by the
echo chambers who tell me what i'm
supposed to think
i'm constantly evolving learning and
doing my best to do so without ego
and with empathy please be patient with
me as far as i'm aware
i do not have any derangement syndromes
nor do i get a medical prescription of
blue
red white or black pills if i say
something
i say it because i'm genuinely thinking
and struggling
with the ideas i have no agenda
just a bit of a hope to add more love to
the world
if you enjoyed this thing subscribe on
youtube review
on apple podcast follow on spotify
support it on patreon or connect with me
on twitter at lex friedman
and now here's my conversation with
sagar
and jetty there's no uh better gifts in
this world
than a book about hitler so thank you so
much
i i've gotten a gift when i was what
were you talking about yes blind right
the watch from joe rogan
and this almost beats it so uh
so tell me what uh this particular book
on hitler is so this is volume two
yes so this is ian kershaw he wrote the
famous
two volume on hitler i'm a big book nerd
and
i spend a lot of time reading
biographies in particular so this one
um if you need a one volume rise and
fall the third reich
right i think you talked about that
william shire because that's like
hitler's rise nazi germany the war etc
but
i like bios because it's the
good biography is story of the times
right and so this one
the first volume it does exactly that
which is that it doesn't just tell the
story of hitler it's the context of
poor you know this kid in austria and
he's got all these dreams but then
actually pretty courageous in terms of
world war one right gets pinned to metal
on by the kaiser and then
what it's like to have to lose world war
one and actually like lose
this the stain and then the rise within
everybody knows that story the beer hall
push and all that this one i like
and the reason i like kirchhoff is
obviously number one it's english which
is
actually hard right like in order to
write that story who can do
both the primary source material and
then translate it for people like us but
he tells
the dynamic story of hitler so well
um in the second volume just like the
the level of detail and you've you've
talked about this lex like
what was it like inside that room inside
with chamberlain
like what was it like in terms of who
was this like magnetic
madman who did convince the smartest
people in the world at the time and
you know up until like 1940 the soviet
gamble
like was a trump he took tremendous
risks
but like highly calculated thinking no
no i'm not gonna pay for this one i'm
not gonna pay for this one
and it put himself he had a remarkable
ability not just to put himself in the
minds of the german people
but in terms of his adversaries like
with when he was across from mussolini
cow kill he's like how exactly did
mussolini the guy who created fascism
becomes like
second fiddle to hitler i think it's an
amazing bio
and yeah like ian kershaw along with
richard evans two of my favorite authors
on the third reich no question
do you think he was born this way that
charisma whatever that is or
was it something he developed
strategically that's like the question
you applied to some of the great
leaders was he just a madman
who had the instinct to be able to
control people when
in the room together with them or is
this like he worked at it i think he
worked at it and but but
also there is an innate quality i'm
forgetting his name
his lifelong rudolph the one who flew to
berlin in like 1940
anyway so he he helped hitler write
minecon and he was like
slavishly devoted to him in prison
this is 1925 or something like that
and so you read that and you're like
well how does he get this like
crank wacko to basically believe he's
like the second coming
help him write this book i mean
literally they lived together in the
prison cell and they would wake up every
day and as he was composing
mineconf and because of the beer hall
putch and all that had this like
absolute ability to gather people around
him
i think his greatest skill was is he was
just a very good politician
truly i mean if you look at his ability
in order to read
coalitional politics and then convince
exactly the right people
in order to follow him i think i heard
you ask this once and i've thought about
it a lot which is like
who could have stopped hitler in germany
right like it's always like the
ever-present question of course like the
whole baby kittler thing really the
answer is hindenburg like hindenburg was
the person
who could have stopped and had the
immense standing within the german
public
the only you know real like war hero
definitely was personally skeptical of
fascism and nazism
and then and didn't like him and he knew
he was full of [ __ ] he was like yeah i
think the sky is dangerous i think this
guy
could do a lot of damage to the republic
but he
acceded basically to hitler at the time
and i think that he was one of the main
people who could have done something
about it
and also he was able to uh convince the
generals the military i mean that was
that was very interesting and to
convince chamberlain and
the other political leaders there's
that's something i
often think about because we're just
reading books about these people
i think about what like jeffrey epstein
for example oh yeah
like evil people not evil but people
have done evil things
let's not go to the dan carl and they go
people that do evil things i wonder what
they are like in a room because i know
quite a lot of
intelligent people that were
did not see uh did not see the evil in
jeffrey epstein
and spend time with him and not were not
bothered by in the same sense
hitler it seems like he was able to get
just even on before he would have power
because people get intoxicated by power
and so on
they want to be close to power but even
before he had power he was able to
convince people
and it's unclear like is there something
that's more than words it's like the way
you i mean that people talk tell stories
about like this piercing
look or whatever all that kind of stuff
i i wonder if that
if that's somehow a part of it like that
has to be the base floor
of any of these charismatic leaders you
have to be able to
in a room alone be able to convince
anybody of anything so i can tell you
from my personal experience one of the
best
educated lessons i got was when i got
to meet trump so i interviewed trump
four different times
as a journalist spent like two and a
half hours with him
in the oval office not alone but like me
and one person and like the press
secretary and that was it so i actually
got to observe him
and as a guy who reads these types of
books right and you know you think of
trump
obviously most people what they see on
television you know in articles and more
but being able to observe it like
one-on-one i was closer to him than you
know than i am
right now from you that was
one of the most educational experiences
i got because it's like you just said
the look the the leaning forward the way
he talks he the way he is a master at
taking the question and answering
exactly which party wants and then if
you try and follow up he's like excuse
me
you know like he knows and then whenever
you're talk it's not that he's
annoyed about getting interrupted if he
realizes he's been miranda
and then you interrupt him all good but
if he's driving home a point which he
has to make sure appears in your
transcript or whatever
it's it's like it really was fascinating
for me
to look at and what was also crazy with
trump
is i realized how much he was living in
the moment so like
when i went to the oval you know i've
read all these biographies and like
i walk in i'm like holy [ __ ] you're like
i'm in the oval office well you
interviewed him in the oval office
noble every time i was in the oval
office you're scared shitless sorry well
i wasn't scared i was just look it's the
oval office right i mean
i'm this nerd he was like this kid i'm
admit this here like i printed out on my
dad's label maker when i was like seven
and i wrote like the oval office on my
bedroom so i was like you know a huge
nerd like obviously you go maniacal even
from seven
but so like for this i mean it was huge
right i'm like this 25 year old kid and
like i walk in there
and like i see the couch right and i'm
like oh man like that's
kissinger like you know i'm like that's
where like kissinger and nixon got on
their knees
and you see over by the door and you're
like are the scuff marks still there
from when eisenhower
used to play it you know this is all
running through my mind yeah trump none
of it was there yeah none of it right so
like
in the moment even the desk i put my
phone on the desk to record yeah and i'm
like this is the [ __ ] resolution
like i shouldn't put my phone on this
thing yeah and and i'm like hms resolute
you know all the international
and even for him he doesn't think about
any of it it was like
amazing to me like he had this portrait
of andrew jackson right next to his
to the uh i think from on the fireplace
like right here on the right and
the most revealing question was when i
was like mr president what are people
gonna remember you for in a hundred
years
and he was like he had he was like i
don't know like veteran's choice
he like has a list in front of him of
like his
accomplishments which is station by the
way yeah well i
i mean that's what i wanted to know and
he's like veteran's choice and i
remember looking at him being like
it's not going to be better you feel
like i'd be like i'm like i'm looking at
you
donald trump the harbinger of something
new yeah we still don't know what the
hell it is
and so i realized with these guys and
their charisma and more
is that they don't think about
themselves the way that we think about
them and that was actually important to
understand because
a lot of people like trump is playing
all this chess i'm like i assure you
he's not
like he's truly living one time i was
interviewing him and he had like a
certificate that he had to sign or
something on his desk
he's like it was like child almost like
he got distracted by he's like oh what's
this you know he's just like picking up
and i was like wow like this
this is the guy like this is what he is
well i wonder
if there was a different person because
you were recording
then it's like offline and i can tell
you well here's the thing though because
that's another part of it because that
two hours i would say like half that was
not on the record
so like whenever he's off the record he
changes
completely right i i don't want to like
go into too much of it or whatever but
like
he uh i mean he is so mindful
of when that camera is on and when the
mic is hot
in terms of the language that he uses
what he's willing to admit
what he's willing to talk about how he's
willing to even appear in front of his
staff
um i think the most revealing thing
trump ever did
was there was this press conference like
right after he lost you the
right after the midterm elections in
2018 and one of the journalists was like
mr president
thank you for doing this press
conference and he looks at him and he
goes
it's called earned media it's worth
billions he just he just
like had so much disdain for him because
he's like i'm not doing this for you
he's like i'm doing this for me so he's
really aware of the narrative
story i mean that the people have talked
about that all comes from the tabloid
media of
the from new york and so on he's a
master of that
but i've also heard stories of just in
private
he's a really i don't want to overuse
the word charismatic but just like
he is a really interesting almost
like um friendly like a good person
like like that's what i heard uh i've
heard actually surprising the same thing
about hillary clinton
uh and like
but like the the way they present
themselves is
perhaps very different than they are as
human beings one-on-one that
that's something uh maybe that's just
like a skill thing
maybe maybe the way they present
themselves in public is actually their
their uh i mean almost their real self
and they're just
really good in private one-on-one to go
into this mode
of just being really intimate in some
kind of human way i think that's part of
it because i i would notice that with
trump you know he's like
it's almost like a tour guide it was
very like it's it's very crazy right
because you're like you're in the oval i
mean it's his office
and he's like he's like do you guys want
anything he's like he want a diet coke
because he drinks like all this diet
coke
that's like you know what he's great
apologize yeah he's just like
he's like you guys want a diet coke
right and you're sitting there and
you're like
the way he he's able to like like
the last time i interviewed him he he
wanted to do it outside
um because he like he's studied himself
from all angles and he knows exactly how
he looks
on a camera and with the witch lighting
and so we were supposed to interview him
on camera in the oval office which is
actually rare like you don't usually get
that
and they ended up moving it outside at
the last minute and he came out and he's
like i picked this spot for you he's
like great lighting
yeah i was like you are your own like
lightning director
yeah the president is great it's so
funny
but it's like you said he's he's very
charismatic
and if friendly i mean you wouldn't i
mean look
this is what i mean in terms of dynamism
of these people
that gets lost and i think even he knows
that like i don't think he would want
that side of him
that i see you know they've seen those
off the record moments and more
in order to come out because he's very
keen about
how exactly he presents to the public
it's like you know even his presidential
portrait
everybody usually smiles and he refused
to smile he was like i want to look like
winston churchill
you know like even he knew that do you
think he believes that he
um what what he kind of implies
that he is one of if not the greatest
presidents in
american history like people kind of
laugh at this but there's quite
i mean there's quite a lot of people
first of all that make the argument that
he's the greatest
president in history like i've heard
this argument being made
and i mean i don't know what the first
of all i don't care
like you can't make an
argument that anyone is the greatest
that's just that just uh i
i come from a school of like being
humble and modest and so on
it's like even michael you can't have a
conversation
okay uh so i like that he's humble
enough to say like uh abraham lincoln
and whatever like
i don't know he says maybe lincoln maybe
remember that
do you think he actually believes that
or is that something he understands
will uh create news and also
perhaps more importantly piss off a
large number of people
is is he almost like a musician
masterfully playing
the emotions of the public or does he
or or and does he believe when he looks
in the mirror i'm one of the greatest
men in history combination of all three
um i do think he believes it
and for the reason why is i don't think
he knows that much about us history i
i really mean that like and that's what
i meant whenever i was in there and i
realized he was just
living in the moment i don't think he
knew all that much
about why i mean this is why i was
elected in many ways right so i'm not
i'm not saying
this is an orbit like i'm not making a
judgment on this i'm just saying
i do think in his mind he does think he
was one of the best
presidents in american history largely
because and i encountered this a lot of
people work for him which is that they
didn't really know all that much
kind of about what came before and all
that and
it's not necessarily to hold it against
them because for in many ways it's what
they were elected to do
or elected to be in many ways it's an
interesting question whether
knowing history being a student of
history is a
is productive or counterproductive i
tend to assume
i really respect people who are deeply
like
well read in history like presidents
that are almost
like nerd history nerds i admire that
uh but maybe that gets in the way well
it's
well governance i don't know it's not
it's not you know
i'm just sort of playing devil's
advocate to my own beliefs
but it's possible that focusing on the
moment and the issues
and letting history it's like first
principles thinking forget
the lessons of the past and just focus
on common sense reasoning through the
problems of today
yeah it's really hard question in terms
of the modern era i mean obama was a
student of history
like he used to have presidential
biographers and people over
and i mean famously like robert de caro
one of my favorite presidential
biographers he was invited to you know
have dinner with obama
and obama would like pepper some of his
every it was interesting because he'd
try and justify some of the things he
didn't do by being like well if you look
at what they had to do and what
i have to deal with mine's much harder
so in that way i was a little pissed off
because
i'd be like no that actually like you're
comparing apples to oranges
and all that but if you look at
roosevelt
teddy roosevelt in particular this was i
mean
a voracious reader not of just american
history all history he
wrote he's just such a badass jesus
incredible
the only the only president who willed
himself to greatness
that's like the amazing thing about him
he wasn't tested by a crisis
right like it wasn't not he didn't have
civil war he didn't have world war ii he
didn't have to found the country
literally or like
you know didn't have to stave off that
or he didn't buy
you know louisiana purchase like all
that he literally came into a
pretty you know static country and he
could have just
governed you know with i mean he was the
person
who came before him was assassinated
like he easily
could have coasted but he literally
willed the country into
something more and that is that's always
why i focused a lot on him too because
i'm like
that in many ways i wouldn't say it's
easy to be great during crisis i mean
like look at trump right but like but
there it can bring out the best within
you
yes but it's a whole other level to
bring out the best within yourself
just for the sake of doing it yeah
that's what i think is really
interesting the speeches were
amazing i'm also a sucker for great
speeches because
i i tend to uh see the role the
president
is in part like inspire in chief
sort of uh to be able to i mean that's
what great leaders do
like ceos of companies and so on
establish a vision a clear vision
and like like hit that hard but the way
you establish division isn't just like
not to dig at joe biden but like like
sleepy boring statements you have to
sell those statements
and you have to you know you have to do
it in a way where everybody's paying
attention everybody's excited yes
and uh that uh teddy roosevelt was
definitely one of them
obama was i think at least early on i
i don't know uh was incredible at that
it does feel that the modern political
landscape makes it more
difficult to be inspirational in the
sense because everything becomes
bickering in division i do want to ask
you please
about trump us you're now
a successful podcaster i've talked to
joe
about trump uh joe rogan and
joe's not interested in talking to trump
it's just fascinating i try to dig into
like
why yeah uh what
would you interview uh trump on like
realignment for example
and uh do you think it's possible to do
a two
three hour conversation with him where
you will get at something
like human or you get something like we
were talking about the facade
he puts forward do you think you could
get past that
no i don't i i look i was a white house
correspondent i observed
i observed this man very closely i
interviewed him
i think if that mic is hot he knows what
he's doing he just he's
he's done this too long lex he just
knows but do you think he's a different
human now after the election
do you think that not at all i don't
i think he's been the same person since
1976.
i i really do like basically 1976
i studied trump a lot and i think he's
basically been the core of who he is
and elements of that ever since he built
that
cent you know the ice rink in central
park and got that media attention
that was it yeah he's a fascinating
study i still i feel
uh there's a hope in me that there would
be a podcast like
uh like a joe rogan like a long form
pockets where something could be
you know and you're actually a really
good person to do that
where you can have a real conversation
that looks back at the election and
reveals something on us but
perhaps he's thinking about running
again and so maybe he'll never let down
that guard yes
but like you know i i just love it when
um
there's this switch in people where
you start start looking back at your
life
and wanting to tell stories like you
know
trying to extract wisdom and like
realizing you're in this new phase of
life where
like the battles have all been fought
now you're this old
like former warrior and now you can tell
the stories of that time
and it seems like trump is still at it
like the young warrior he is he's not
in the mode of telling stories you know
what i got from rogan he's the only
president who didn't age while in office
it's true right like because and this is
what i mean because he lives in the
moment like the job
actually aged obama i mean i mean bush
same thing even clinton clinton was like
fat yeah
he looked miserable by like 2000 hw
like i mean reagan famous actually yeah
pretty much everybody i think about
um yeah including john f kennedy who got
much sicker while in office
the job like weighs on you and makes you
physically ill
trump was he's the only person who just
knows he doesn't have to do it he almost
gotten stronger and he was one of the
most divisive
like the climate there's so many people
attacking him
so much hatred so much love and hatred
and it was just he's it was
i mean it was uh whatever it was it was
uh
quite masterful and and a fascinating
study i
if we um if we stick on uh hitler for
just a minute
uh what lessons
do you take from that time do you think
it's a unique moment in human history
that world war ii i mean both stalin and
hitler
you know is it something that's just
an outlier in all of humans history in
terms of the atrocities
or is there uh the lessons to be learned
you mentioned we mentioned offline that
you're not just a student of the
entirety of the history but you also are
fascinated by just different like
policies and stuff like what's the
immigration policy what's the policy on
science and
look third reich in power let me plug it
by richard uh richard evans i think
is what it was because that actually
will tell you like what was it like to
live under the nazi regime without the
war yeah um
yeah it's a hard question in terms of
the lessons that we can learn
because there's a lot and it's actually
been over it's been
over indexed almost everything comes
back to hitler in a conversation so
i kind of think of it within mao stalin
and
hitler as i don't want to say
payments for but like the
end point payment for the sins
and the problems of the monarchical
system
that evolved within europe basically
like 1400
and more i basically think that 1400
the wars between the state you know wars
between france
england the balance of power eventually
world war one and then
serfdom within russia the russian
revolution that birthed stalin
same thing the kaiser and imperial
germany and this like incredibly
crazy system of balance of power in
world war one
and then same thing within china in
terms of the warring states and then
the disintegration the european you know
how this is how they think of it you
know
which is like the center of humiliation
and they had to have
something like this i think of it i try
to think of it within the context of
that
i don't want to think of i don't want to
sound like an inevitabilist
but i think of it as i like to think
about systems
especially here in dc that's why i got
into politics which is that
you have to understand systems of power
and the incentives within systems
and the disincentives and the downside
risk of what you're pur
of what you're creating because it that
is what
leads and creates the behavior
within that system i was just talking to
my girlfriend about this yesterday
it's kind of funny like i read these i'm
obsessed with these books
um by robert carro the biographies of
lyndon johnson he's written like 5
000 pages so far and it's still not done
okay so like these are
these are like books i base my life on
and
look these are washington and the story
of the post new deal era and forward
not much has changed like the senate is
the still the senate
so many of the same problems with the
senate are still there um in some cases
no not not anymore but for a while some
of the people who were there with
johnson are actually still
um one of them is the president of the
united states just a joke
and you think about also same with the
media relationship right like there's
this media really
they may have come and gone like the the
people who were in the media and who
were
cozy with the administration officials i
mean they just recreated themselves
it's like this it's like an ecosystem
which doesn't change
and the that's why i'm like oh it's not
that was a specific time that's just dc
like that is dc because
of the way the system is architected
it's pretty much been that way since
like 1908
whenever like you know teddy roosevelt
was dining with these journalists and he
would yell at them and then he would go
over to
the society house and like in many ways
that's now instead of going to henry
adams's house
like the people are congregating in
calorama
um which is the richest neighborhood
here at somebody else's house like it's
the same
thing so you have to think about the
system and then the incentives within
that system
about what the outcomes that they're
producing if you actually want to think
about
how can i change this from the outside
that's also why it's very difficult to
change
because the system is designed in order
to produce
actually pretty specific outcomes that
can only be changed in extraordinary
times
yeah and sometimes hard to to predict
what kind of
outcomes will result from the incentive
uh the system that you create right
right in the case because especially
when it's novel kind of situations what
trump actually created a pretty novel
situation and
a lot of the uh things that we've seen
in the 20th century
were very novel systems where people
were very optimistic about
the the the outcomes right and then it
turned out to
not have the results that they predicted
i
in terms of like things being unchanged
for the past hundred years and so on
can you um like wikipedia style or maybe
like in in a musical form like i'm only
a bill
describe to me uh i i still sing that to
my head sometimes
i'm just a bill
uh i don't know what the rest of the
song is but let's let's uh let's
leave that to people's imagination uh
how how does this whole thing work how
does the us political system work
the three branches is how do you think
about
the system we have now if you were to
try to describe
if aliens showed up and asked you
like they didn't have time so this is an
elevator
thing should we destroy you yeah and be
as you plead to avoid destruction
how how would you uh describe how this
thing works i would say
we come together and we pick the people
who make
our laws then we pick the guy
who executes those laws and they
together
pick the people who determine whether
they
or the president is breaking the law at
the most basic level
that's how i would describe it so the
so that's the people who make the laws
are congress the executive
is is charged with executing
the laws as passed by congress the
system the branches of government
and the supreme court is picked by the
president confirmed by the senate
which then decides whether you or
other people are breaking the law in
terms of interpretation
of that law that's basically it oh and
they
they decide whether those laws are
in they fall within the
they fall within the restrictions
and the want of the founders as
expressed
by the constitution of the united states
which is a set of principles that we
came together
in 1787. i want to make sure i get this
right
um 1787 and decided that we were going
to live
the rest of our lives barring a
revolution and more and we've made it
200 and something years
in order on under that system so there's
a balance of power there's because we
have
multiple branches there's attention and
a balance to it
as designed by those original documents
uh
what which is the most dysfunctional the
branches which is your favorite
like uh in terms of talking about
systems and like
what's the greatest of concern and what
is the greatest
source of benefit in your view the
presidency obvious well the presidency
is my favorite to study obviously
because
it is the one where there's the most
subjective variable change
in terms of the personality involved
because of so much power imbued within
the executive
the senate is actually pretty much the
same
one of the things i love about reading
about the senate and histories of the
senate is you're like oh yeah there were
always
like [ __ ] in the senate who were
doing their thing and
and you know filibustering constantly
based upon
this or that and then the pers the
personalities involved with the senate
haven't mattered as much since
like pre-civil war right like pre-civil
war you had like henry clay and then
daniel webster and john c calhoun who
even in their own way they represented
like larger constituencies and they
crafted these like compromises
up until the outbreak of the civil war
et cetera but like post since
then you don't think about like the
titans within the senate
most of that is because a lot of the
stuff that they had power over has
transferred over
to the executive so i'm most interested
in really in like
power like where it lies it's actually
pretty you know throughout american
history
much more used to lie with congress now
it's obviously just so
imbued within the executive that
understanding executive power
is i think the thing i'm probably most
interested in here do you think at this
point
the amount of power the president has is
corrupting to the
to their ability to lead well is this is
you know
uh power corrupts absolute power
corrupts absolutely
are we uh is there too much power in the
in the presidency
there definitely is and part of the
problem i one of the things i try
to make come across to people is
if you're the president unless you have
a
hyper intentional view of how something
must be different in government
your view doesn't matter so for example
like if you were
trump let's take trump even and even him
with a pretty intentional view he was
like i'm gonna end the war in
afghanistan
and iraq right and he came in and he
gets these generals in he's like i want
to end the war in afghanistan and iraq
oh and i want to withdraw these troops
from syria and they're like
okay we'll give you give us like six
months he's like okay and this is the
thing about trump he doesn't realize
that it's [ __ ]
so they're like he's like six months
seems fine right so then six months
comes
and he's like he's like so and then
he'll announce it he'll be like and
we're getting out of syria
it's great and then the generals freak
out they're like whoa
whoa we don't have a plan for that he's
like but you guys told me six months
he's like i don't know now we need
another six months in order to figure
this thing out yeah
and by that time now you're midterms so
now what now you gotta run for
re-election
so more what i mean by that is if you
don't have a hyper-intentional view
about how to change foreign policy
if you don't have a hyper-intentional
view about how the department of
commerce should do its job
they are just gonna go on autopilot so
there's
this is part of the problem when you ask
me about the presidency it's
not the presidency itself like the
president himself
which has become too powerful it's that
we have less
democratic checks on the
people and the systems that are on
autopilot
and i would say that basically since
2008 we have voted
every single time to disrupt that system
except in the case of 2020 with joe
biden and there are a lot of different
reasons around
why that happened and in every single
one of those cases
obama and trump they all failed in order
to
in order to radically disrupt that and
that just shows you how titanic
the task is and i'm using my language
precisely because i don't want to be
like deep state and all but like
obviously there's a deep state deep
state i guess has conspiratorial
attention to it but so you're what
you're saying is
the true power currently lies with the
autopilot
aka deep state well but see it's not
this is the thing too i want to make
and clear because i think people think
conspiratorially that they're all coming
together to
intentionally do something no no no no
they are doing
what they know believe they are right
and don't have real democratic checks
within that
and so now they have entire generations
of cultures within each of these
bureaucracies
where they say this is the way that we
do things
around here yeah and that's the problem
which is that
we have a culture of within
many of these agencies and more i think
the best example for this
would be during the ukraine you know
gate with trump and all that with the
impeachment now
i'm not talking about the politics here
but the most revealing thing
that happened was when the whistleblower
guy alexander vinman
was like here you have the president
departing from the policy of the united
states
and i was like well um let me educate
you
lieutenant colonel um the president of
the united states
makes american foreign policy yeah but
it was a very revealing comment
because he and me all the people within
national security bureaucracy
do think that they're like this is the
policy of the united states it's we we
have to do this
that's where things get screwy well
listen for me personally yeah but also
from an
engineering perspective i just talked to
jim keller it's just
this is the kind of [ __ ] that we all
hate in uh when you're trying
to innovate and design new like products
right so like that's the that's what
first principles thinking
requires is like we don't give a [ __ ]
what was done before
the point is what is the best way to do
it and it seems like
uh the current government government in
general
probably bureaucracies in general are
just
really good at being lazy about never
having those conversations
and just it becomes this momentum thing
that nobody has the difficult
conversations
it's become a game within a certain set
of constraints
and they never kind of do revolutionary
tasks but you did say that the
presidency has power but you're saying
that
more power than the others and
but that power has to be coupled with
like focused intentionality like you
have to keep
hammering the thing if you want it done
it has to be done
i mean and you gotta you gotta this is
the other part too which
is that it's not just that you have to
get it done you have to pick
the 100 people who you can trust to pick
10 people each to actually do what you
want
one of the most revealing quotes is from
a guy named tommy corcoran he was the
top aide to fdr this i'm getting from
the cara books too
and he said what is a government it's
not just
one guy or even 10 guys hell it's
a thousand guys and what fdr
did is he masterfully picked the right
people
to execute his will through the federal
agencies johnson was the same way
he played these people like a fiddle he
knew exactly
who to pick he knew the system and more
part of the reason that outsiders who
don't have a lot of experience in
washington
almost always fail is they don't know
who to pick or
they pick people who say one thing to
their face and then
when it comes time to carry out the
president's policy in terms of the
government
they just don't do it and the
president's too think about this i think
some
rahm emanuel said this he was like by
the time it gets to the president's desk
nobody else can solve it it's not easy
it's not like a yes or no question it's
every single thing that hits the
president's desk is incredibly hard
to do and obama actually even said and
this was a very revealing quote about
how
how he thinks about the presidency which
is he's like look
the presidency is like one of those
super tankers
you know he's like i can come in and i
can make it two degrees left
and two degrees right in a hundred years
two degrees left
that's a whole different trajectory yeah
same thing on the right and he's like
that
ultimately is really all you can do i
quibble and disagree with that in terms
of how he could have changed things in
2008
but there's a lot of truth to that
statement okay that's really fascinating
you're making me realize that
um actually both obama and trump are
probably
playing victim here to the system you're
making me think that
maybe you can correct me that
because i'm thinking like elon musk
whose
major success despite everything is is
hiring the right people
exactly and like creating those
thousands that
structure of a thousand people so maybe
a president has power in that
if they were exceptionally good at
hiring the right people personnel is
policy man
that's that's what it comes down to but
wouldn't you be able to steer the ship
way more than two degrees if you hire
the right people so like
it's almost like obama was not good at
hiring the right people well he hired
all the clinton people
yeah that's what happened what happened
with trump he hired all the bush people
and then you sit back and say
oh president can't but that means you're
just
sucking hiring correct yeah i mean look
i know it's funny i'm giving you
simultaneously the nationalist case
against trump yeah and the progressive
case against obama yes the progressive
people were like
why the [ __ ] are you hiring all these
clinton people in order to run the
government
and just recreate like why are you
hiring larry summers
who was one of the people who worked at
all these banks and didn't believe the
bailouts were gonna be big enough
and then to come in in the worst
economic crisis in modern american
history
that was 2008 and summers actively
lobbied against larger bailouts which
had huge implications for
working class people and pretty much
hollowed out america since
okay from trump same thing you're like
i'm gonna drain the swamp
and by doing that i'm gonna hire goldman
sachs as
gary cohn and steve mnuchin and
all these other absolute bush clowns
in order to run my white house well yeah
no [ __ ] the only thing that you
accomplished
in your four years in office is passing
a massive tax cut for the rich
and for corporations i wonder how that
happened
what role does money play in all this is
money
huge influence in politics uh super pacs
all that kind of stuff
or is this is this more just kind of a
narrative that we play with
because from the outsider's perspective
it seems to have
that seems to be one of the fundamental
problems with modern politics so i was
just having this conversation
marshall and i marshall castle of my
co-host on the realignment and
it's funny because if you do enough
research we actually live
in the least corrupt age in american
uh campaign finance as in it's never
been more transparent
it's never been more up to the f fec
yeah and all of that if you go back and
read not even 50 years ago we're talking
about lyndon b johnson handing people
like literally as he came up in his
youth
paying people for votes like the boss of
the you know
the person who like had all the mexican
boats like the person who had and he was
like giving out briefcases
this is like within people's lifetimes
who are alive in america
so that doesn't happen anymore but i
don't like to blame everything on money
although i do think money is obviously
a huge part of the problem i actually
look at it in terms of
distribution um which is that how is
money distributed with an artist
within our society because i firmly
believe
that politics this is going to get
complicated but i think politics is
mostly downstream from culture and
culture
obviously i'm using economics because
there's obviously a huge interplay there
but like
in terms of the equitable or lack of
equitable distribution of money within
our politics
what we're really pissed off about is
we're like our politics only seems to
work
for the people who have money i think
that's largely true
um i think that the reason why things
worked differently in the past
is because our economy was structured in
different ways
and there's a reason that our politics
today are very analogous
to the last gilded age because we had
very similar levels
levels of economic distribution and
cultural problems too at the same time i
don't want to erase that because i
actually think that's what's driving
all of our politics right now so that's
interesting so yeah
that's one so in that sense
representative government is doing a
pretty good job of representing it is
the state of culture and the people and
so on yeah uh
can i ask you uh in terms of um you know
the deep state and conspiracy theories
there's a lot of talk about so again
from an outsider's perspective
if i were just looking at twitter it
seems that at least ninety percent of
people in government are pedophiles
90 to 95 i'm not sure what that number
is
if i were to just look at twitter
honestly or youtube i would think
most of the world is a pedophile i would
almost feel like
right and if you don't fully believe
that you're a pedophile
yeah yeah yeah i would start to wonder
like wait am i like
what am i a pedophile too i'm either a
communist or a pedophile or both
i guess uh yeah that's going to be
clipped out thank you
internet i look forward to your emails
uh but is there any kind of
shadow conspiracy theories that
uh give you pause or um
so the flip side the response to a lot
of conspiracy theories it's like
no the reason this happened is because
it's a combination of
just incompetence so where do you land
on
some of these uh conspiracy theories i
think
most conspiracy theories are wrong some
are true
and those are spectacularly true and
if that makes sense yeah um i and we
don't know which ones
i don't know which one that's the
problem i think oh well i mean look man
i listened to your podcast
i think i was a huge non-believer in
ufos
and now i've probably never believed
more in uf like i
i believe in ufos like i'm very
comfortable being like
not only do i believe in ufos like i
think we're probably being visited by an
alien civilization
like and if you asked me that three
years ago i would be like you're out of
your [ __ ] mind like what are you
talking about
well listen to david fraber that's all i
have to say that's it well i
i have the sense that the government has
information that
hasn't revealed but it's not like
they're i don't think they're holding
there's like a green guy sitting there
exactly they just
they have seen things they don't know
what to do with so it's like
they're confused like they're afraid
yeah of revealing that they don't know
that's what i think it is right it's
revealing the yeah exactly
you don't know and then they're in the
process there's a lot of fears tied up
in that first
looking incompetent in the public eye
nobody wants to be
uh looked that way and the other is like
in revealing it
even though they don't know maybe china
will figure it out exactly
so like we don't want china to figure it
out first and so that
all those kinds of things result in
basically secrecy then
that damages the trust in institutions
on one of the most fascinating
aspects like one of the most fascinating
mysteries of humankind
of is there life intelligent life out
there in the universe
so that's one of them but there there's
other ones like uh
for me when i first came across actually
alex jones
was 9 11. yeah i remember like because i
was um
i was in chicago i was thinking like oh
[ __ ] are they gonna hit chicago too
that's what everybody was thinking yeah
everybody everybody was thinking like
what does this mean let's get what scale
what
i mean trying to interpret it and i
remember like looking for information
that's been like what what happened
what and i remember not being satisfied
with
the quality of reporting and figuring
out like
rigorous like here's exactly what
happened
and so people like alex jones stepped up
and others that said like
there's some shady [ __ ] going on and it
sure as hell looked like there's shady
[ __ ] going on
yes uh so like and i still stand behind
the fact that it seems like there's not
i there's
and then i mean that is that was a
conspiracy theory not that long ago
i think it's true i mean i think it's
100 true yeah so
those kinds of conspiracy theories are
interesting i mean there's other ones
for me personally that touched uh the
institution that
means a lot to me is mit and uh
you know jeffrey epstein yeah i want to
hear a lot more i want to hear about
that
i talk about epstein a lot so i'm like
oh you do yeah and and he
i was going to say in terms of
conspiracy theory that one changed my
outlook because i was like
i was like whoa like you have this dude
who
convinced some of the most successful
people on earth
that he was like some money manager and
it looks like
it was totally fake like leon black i
mean this is one of the richest men on
wall street nine billion dollar
net worth why has he given him over a
hundred million dollars between 2015 and
2019
yeah what's going on here lex wexner
same thing so yeah i want to hear
because
you know people who met him and the only
person i know who met him was eric
weinstein i've heard his
right oh boy so i listen i'm still lynn
and
eric is fascinating and like eric is
full-on
saying that he was a mossad or
uh something much much bigger um
and there's uh whatever his name robert
maxwell all the
all those stories like you could dig
deeper and deeper that
jeffrey's just like the tip of the
iceberg
i just think he's an exceptionally
charismatic
listen this isn't speaking from
confidence or like
deep understanding the situation but for
my
speaking with people he just seems like
at least from the side of his influence
and interaction with researchers he just
seems like somebody that was
exceptionally charismatic
and actually took interest
he was unable to speak about interesting
scientific things
but he took interest in them so he knew
how to stroke the egos of a lot of
powerful people like well
like in in different kinds of ways i
suppose
i don't know about this because i don't
have
like if a really okay this is this is
weird to say but
i have an ability okay i think
women are beautiful i like women but
like if if like a supermodel came to me
or something like
like i'm able to reason it seems like
some people
yes are not able to think clearly when
there's like an attractive woman in the
room
and i think that was one of the tools he
used
to manipulate people interesting i don't
know
listen it's like the pedophile thing
right i don't know how many people are
complete sex addicts but like it seems
like
like looking out into the world like
there's a with like the metoo movement
have revealed that there's a lot of like
weird
like uh creepy people out there i don't
know
but i think it was just one of the many
tools that he used
uh to uh convince people and manipulate
people but not in some
like um evil way
but more just really good at the art of
conversation
and just winning people over on the side
and then by building through that
process building a network of other
really powerful people
and not explicitly but
implicitly having done shady [ __ ]
with powerful people yeah like building
up a kind of
implied power of like
like we did some shady [ __ ] together
so we're not like you're going to help
me out on this extra thing i need to
know and that builds and builds and
builds
to where you're able to actually control
like have quite a lot of power without
explicitly having like a strategy
meeting
and i think a single person or
yeah i think a single person can do that
or can start that ball rolling
and over time it becomes a group thing
like i don't know if
julian maxwell was involved or others
and yeah over time that becomes almost
like a really powerful organization
that wasn't that's not a front for
something
much deeper and bigger but it's almost
like maybe it's because i love cellular
automata man
a system that starts out as a simple
thing with simple rules
can create incredible complexity yes and
so i just think that
uh we're now looking in retrospect it
looks like an incredibly complex system
that's operating in
but like that's just because it's you
know there could be a lot of other
jeffrey epstein's
in in my perspective that this simple
thing just
uh was successful early on it builds and
builds and builds and builds
and then there's uh creepy [ __ ] that
like a lot of aspects of the system
helped it get bigger and bigger and more
powerful and so on
so the final result is i mean
listen i have a pretty optimistic i have
i tend to see the good in people and so
it's been heartbreaking to me in general
just to see
you know people i look up to not have
the level of integrity i thought they
would
or like the strength of character all
those kinds of things
and it seems like you should be able to
to see the [ __ ] that is jeffrey
epstein like when you meet him
right uh we're not talking about like
eric weinstein like one or two or three
or five interactions
but like there's people that had like
like years of relationship with him yeah
and i don't know i i'm not sure even
after he was convicted
after he was convicted yeah there's
there's stories i mean i don't need to
sort of
uh i honestly believe
okay here's the open question i have i
don't
know how many creepy sexual people that
are out there
like i don't know if there's like
like the people i know the faculty and
so on
i don't know if they have like a kink
that i'm just not aware of that was
being leveraged because to me it seems
like
if if if people aren't if not
everybody's a pedophile
[Laughter]
then it's just the art of conversation
that is just like the art of just like
manipulating people by making them feel
good about
like the exciting stuff they're doing
listen man academics are people talk
about money
i don't think academics care about money
as much as people think
what they care about is like somebody
they they want to be uh it's the same
thing that instagram models
post in their butt pictures is they want
to be loved
they want attention my parents are
professors yeah
they they and jeff epstein the money
is another way to show attention right
it's my work matters and and and he
for some of he did that for some of the
weirdest most brilliant people i don't
want to sort of
drop names but everybody knows them it's
like people that are
the most interesting academics is the
one he cared about yeah
like people are thinking about the most
difficult questions
of in all of science and all of
engineering so those people
are we're kind of outcasts in academia a
little bit because they're doing the
weird [ __ ] they were the weirdos
and he cared about the weirdos and he
gave them money and that
uh you know i that's i don't know if
there's something more nefarious than
that
i i i hope not but maybe i'm surprised
and in fact the half the population of
the world is
pedophiles no i i think it's what you
were talking about which is that
it's the it's the implication
after the initial right like you do some
shady things together or you do
something that you want out of the
public eye and you're a public person
and look we probably even experienced
this to a limited extent right you're
like
you know like i don't wanna i don't
almost lost my temper you know one time
whenever a car hit me and i'm like i
can't freak out in public anymore
that you know like what if somebody
takes a photo or something yeah and so
i think that there's an extent to that
times a billion
literally when you have a billion
dollars or more and you take that all
together and you stack it up on itself
i saw a story about like bill clinton
like bill clinton was with epstein
or with gelane maxwell in a private air
terminal or something
and she had one of their like sex you
know
one of those girls who was underage had
her dressed up in a literal like pilot
uniform
and she was underage in order to you
know and she was just
being disguised for being older and she
was a masseuse
right because that was one of the uh
guyses which they got in order to
sexually traffic these women
and she was like bill was like
complaining about his neck and she's
like give bill clinton a
massage right so now there's a photo of
an underage girl giving a massage
to the former president of the united
states i don't think he knew
right but like that looks bad and so
this is kind of what we're getting at
which is that you're setting it all up
and creating those preconditions
or like prince andrew do i think prince
andrew knew that virginia gouffrey
was underage i don't know probably knew
she was pretty young
which i think is you know skeevy enough
where if you're a [ __ ] prince you
should probably know better yeah
but i don't think he knew she was
underage or maybe he did and if he did
and he's even
more of a piece of [ __ ] than i thought
but we when we when we look at these
things
the the stuff i'm more interested in is
like what you were talking about i'm
like bill gates
how do you get the richest man in the
world in your house
yeah like under what got and gates is
like he was talking about financing and
all this i'm like
you don't have access to money or
bankers like
you're the richest man in the world you
can call goldman sachs
anytime you want on a hotline like why
do you need
that's where that's where i start again
to get more conspiratorial because i'm
like
bill dude you can you have the gold
credit right
like you don't need epstein to create
some complicated financing structure
or leon black like what is
2015 2009 i mean this is very recent
stuff
or and this is the part that really got
me as i read the depart
i think it's called the department of
financial services report around
deutsche bank
with epstein the news a criminal
they solicited his business explicitly
knew
that his business meant access to other
high net worth individuals
consistently doled money out from his
account for hush payments
to women in europe and prostitution
rings they knew all of this
within the bank it was elevated multiple
times
here was the other one one of epson's
associates was like hey how much money
can we take out before we hit the
you know automatic sensor before you
have to tell the irs
and that question by by their own
standards is supposed to result
in a notification to the feds and they
never did it and he was withdrawing like
two million dollars of cash
in five years for tips yeah i'm like
okay
like something's going on here you see
what i'm saying there's a lot of signs
that make you think that there is a
bigger thing at play
than just a man that there is some
it does look like a larger organization
is using this
front right it's again i don't know i i
truly don't know and i'm not willing to
use the certainty which i think a lot of
people online are to say like it wants
one hundred years
the search is always the problem because
that that's probably why
i hesitate to touch conspiracy theories
is because i'm allergic to certainty in
all forms
in politics any kind of discourse and
people are so
sure in both directions actually
it's kind of hilarious uh either
they're sure that the conspiracy theory
particular whatever the conspiracy
theories is false
like they almost dismiss it like
like they don't even want to talk about
it's like the people like the way they
dismiss
that the earth is flat yes most
scientists are like
they don't even want to like hear
what the what the flat earthers are
saying they don't have
like zero patience for it which is like
maybe in that case yeah it's deserved
but everything else
you really like have empathy like
consider the f you have okay this is
weird to say but i feel like
you have to consider that the earth
might be flat
for like one minute like you have to be
empathetic you have to be open-minded
i don't see a lot of that there are
cultural taste makers and more and
that's
that really is what concerns me the most
because it's just another manifestation
of all of our problems
it's that we have this completely
bifurcating economy bifurcating culture
literally in terms of we have the middle
of the country and then we have the
coast
and in terms of the population it's
almost 50 50
and with you know increasing mega cities
and urban
culture like urban monoculture of la new
york and chicago
and dc and boston and austin relative to
how an entire other group of americans
live their lives
or even the people within them who
aren't rich and upwardly mobile
how they live their lives is just
completely separating
and all of our language and
communication in
mass media and more is to the top and
then everybody else is forgotten
do you think when you go when you dick
to the core there is a big
there's a big gap between left and right
is there
is that division that that's perceived
currently
real or are most people look center left
and center right
it's so interesting because that's such
a loaded term
center left what does that mean like
so you i think the way you're thinking
of it is i'm not
like a well even this like i'm not a
radical socialist but i'm uh
i'm marginally left on cultural issues
and economic issues this is how we've
traditionally understood things
um and then when when in popular
discourse like center right like what
does it mean to be center right like
i am marginally right on socially on
conservat on social issues
and marginally right on economic issues
yeah but that's just not
politic like if you look at survey data
for example like
uh stimulus checks people who are
against stimulus checks are conservative
right
well eighty percent of the population is
first stimulus check so that means a
sizable
number of republicans are for stimulus
checks same thing happens on
like a wealth tax um the same thing
happens on
okay florida voted for trump
3.1 more than barack obama 2008.
on the same day passes a 15 minimum wage
at 67
yeah so what's going on so that's why
what is going on
well that's my entire career no but but
it seems like
uh so that's that's fascinating yeah
conversation
is different than the policies well it's
different than reality that's what i
would say which is that
the way we have to understand american
politics
today it didn't always used to be this
way is it's almost
entirely long basic i would say the main
divider
is because even when you talk about
class dismisses it in terms of
socioeconomics
it's around culture which is that
it's basically if you went to a
four-year degree granting institution
you are part of one culture if you
didn't you're part of another
i don't want to erase the 20 or whatever
people who do go to a college degree who
are republicans or vice versa
et cetera but i'm saying on average in
terms of the median
way that you feel we're basically
bifurcating
along those lines and because people get
upset be like oh well
you know there are rich people who vote
for trump and i'm like yeah
but you know you know who they are
they're like plumbers
or something like they're people who
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
but they didn't go to a four-year
college degree and they might live
who are in a place which is not an urban
metro area
and then at the same time you have like
a vox rider
who makes like 30 grand but they have a
lot more
cultural power than like the plumber so
you have
to think about where exactly that line
is and i think
in general that's the way that we're
trending so
that's why when i say like what's going
on are we divided yeah like
but it's not left and right i mean like
and that's why i hate these
labels so it's more it's more just red
and blue like teams they're arbitrary
teams
yeah are they so how arbitrary are these
teams i guess is another completely
arbitrary
so yeah well you kind of imply that
there's i don't know if you're sort of
in post analyzing the patterns because
it seems like there's a network effects
of like you just pick the team red or
blue
and it might have to do with college you
might have to do all those things but
like
it it seems like it's more about
uh just the people around you correct
so less than whether you went to college
or not i mean it's almost like seems
like
it's it's almost like uh weird right
like network effects that
are hard there's certain strong patterns
correct you're identifying
but i don't know it's sad to think that
it might be just
teams that have nothing to do with what
you actually believe
well it is lex i look i mean i don't
want to believe
that but the data points me to this
which especially 2020.
i'm one of the people chief among them i
will own up to it here
i was totally wrong about why trump was
elected in 2016.
i believed and based a lot of my public
commentary beliefs on this
trump was elected because of a rejection
of hillary clinton
neo-liberalism on the back of a
pro-worker
message which was anti-immigration
it was its pillar but alongside of it
was a rejection
of free trade with china and
generally of the political correctness
and globalism
which has been come in through the
uniparty and
same thing here with the military
industrial complex and endless war
he rejected all of that wait what's
wrong with that prediction
it's wrong man and the reason i know
this is that
it sounds right i wish it i honestly
wish it was true
but here's the truth trump actually
governed largely
as a neo-liberal republican who was
meaner online
and who departed from orthodoxy in some
very important ways don't get me wrong i
will always
support the trade war with china i will
always support
not expanding the wars in afghanistan
and in iraq i will support him
moving the overton window on a million
different things and revealing once and
for all that gop voters don't care about
economic orthodoxy necessarily but
here's what they do care about
trump got more votes in 2020 than he did
in 2016
despite not delivering largely largely
for all the trump people out there
on that agenda he wasn't more pro-union
but he won more union votes
he wasn't necessarily more pro-worker
but he actually won more votes in ohio
than he did in 2016. and he won more
hispanic votes
than despite being you know all the
immigration agenda
rhetoric etc here's why it's about the
culture
which is that the culture war is so hot
that negative partisanship is at such
high levels
all of the vote is geared upon what the
other guy might do in office and there's
a poll actually just came out by echelon
insights
crystal and i were talking about it on
rising the number one concern
amongst democratic voters is trump
voters
number one concern not issues
like trump voters and number two is
white supremacy
and so like which is basically code for
trump voters
and it's the same for the other side
well so on the right the number one
concern
is illegal immigration um and number i
think
three or four or whatever is antifa
which is code four
from the right is the policy well well
yeah it's funny
i saw ben shapiro talking about this but
the reason why i would
functionally say it's the same is
because the i mean
you can believe whether it's a true or
not i think it actually largely is true
but like
the a lot of gop voters feel like a lot
of illegal immigration is code for like
people who are coming in who are going
to be legalized and are going to go vote
democrat
like i can i can just explain it from
their point of view so like
what does that actually mean each other
like yeah
each other which is that the number one
concern is
the other person so negative
partisanship has never been higher
and i think people who had my thesis in
terms of why trump was
elected in 2016 you have to grapple with
this like how did he win
10 million more votes he came 44 000
votes away from winning the presidency
across three states
like i don't none of our popular
discourse reflects
that very stark reality and i think
so much of it is people really hate
liberals like they just really hate them
and i was driving through
rural nevada before the election and i
was like
literally in the middle of nowhere and
there was this massive sign this guy had
out
in front of his house and it just said
trump colon [ __ ]
your feelings and i was like that's it
that is why people voted for trump and i
don't want to denigrate it because
they truly feel they have no cultural
power in america
except to raise the middle finger to the
elite class
by pressing the button for trump i get
that that's actually a totally
rational way to vote it's not the way i
wish we did vote but like
you know it's not my place to say so
yeah this is interesting if you could
just psychoanalyze
i'm again i'm probably naive about this
but
i'm really bothered by the hatred of
liberals
it's uh it's this amorphous monster
that's mocked it's like the shapiro
liberal tears and i'm also really
bothered by
probably more of my colleagues and
friends the hatred of trump yeah
uh the the trump and
and white supremacist so apparently 70
there's
70 million white supremacists 75 million
sorry
there's millions of white supremacists
and apparently whatever liberal is i
mean lib
you know you literally liberal has
become
equivalent to white supremacists in the
power of negativity it arouses
i don't even know what those i mean
honestly i just don't they've become
swears essentially
uh is that i mean how do we get
out of this because that uh that's why i
just don't even say anything about
politics online because it's like
really like you you can't
you if here's what happens anything you
say
that's like thoughtful like hmm i wonder
like
immigration something right i wonder
like why you know uh we have
these many we allow these many
immigrants in or
some version of the like thinking
through these difficult policies and so
on
that they'll immediately try to find
like a single word in something you say
they can put you in a bin of liberal
or white supremacist and then hammer you
to death
by saying you're one of the two and then
everybody just piles on
happily that we finally nailed this
white supremacist
or liberal and that
is this some kind of weird like feature
of online communication that we've just
stumbled upon
is there a way or is it possible to
argue that this is like
a feature not a bug like this is a a
good thing
yeah well look i just think it's a
reflection of who we are people like to
blame social media i think we're just
incredibly divided right now i think
we've been divided like this
for the last 20 years and i think that i
can the reason i focus
almost 99 of my public commentary on
economics is because you asked an
important question at the top
how do we fix this what did i say about
the stimulus checks stimulus checks have
80
approval rating so that's the type of
thing if i was joe biden and i wanted to
actually heal this country
that's the very first thing i would have
done when i came into office same thing
on uh when you look at anything that's
gonna increase wages
um i i said on the show i was like look
i think joe biden will have a 80
approval rating if he does two things if
he gives every american
a 2 000 stimulus check and gives
everybody who wants a vaccine a vaccine
that's it it's pretty simple because
here's the thing
i don't really like greg abbott that
much we have like very different
politics i'm from texas
but my parents got vaccinated really
quickly
that means something to me i'm like
listen i don't really
care about a lot of the other stuff he
got my family vaccinated
like that well i will forever
remember that and that's how we will
remember
the checks this isn't part of a reason
why trump almost won the election
and why if the republicans had been
smart enough to give him a 2000
another round of checks 100 would have
won
which is that people were like look i
don't really like trump
but i got a check with his name on it
and that
meant something to me and my family i'm
not saying
for all the libertarians out there that
you should go and like endlessly
spend money and buy votes what i am
saying is
lean into the majoritarian
positions without adding your culture
war [ __ ] on top of it
yeah so for example what's the number
one concern that aoc says after the
first round of checks got out
oh the checks didn't go to illegal
immigrants i'm like are you out of your
[ __ ] mind
like this is the most popular policy
america has probably done
in 50 years you know since like medicare
and you're you're considering it you're
ruining it yeah
and then on the right is the same thing
which is that they'll be like these
checks are going to like you know low
level
blah blah you know people who are lazy
and don't work i'm like oh there you go
you know like you're just playing a
caricature of what you are like if you
lean into those issues and you got to do
it clean
this is this is what everybody hates
about dc which is that
biden right now is doing the 1400 checks
but he's looping it in
with his coveted relief bill and all
that that's his prerogative that's the
democrats prerogative they won the
election that's fine
but i'll tell you what i would have done
if i was him i would have come in
and i would have said there's five
united states senators who are on the
record republicans who say they'll vote
for a two thousand dollar check
and i would put that on the floor of the
united states senate on my you know
first or
the first day possible and i would have
passed it and i would have
forced those republican senators to live
up to that vote for this bill
come to the oval office for a signing so
that the very first thing of my
presidency
was to say i'm giving you all this
relief check
this night long national nightmare is
over take this money
do with it what you need we've all
suffered together
the thing about biden is he has a
portrait of fdr in his
in the oval which kind of bothers me
because he thinks of himself as an
fdr-like figure
but this is you have to understand the
majesty of
fdr we're talking about a person who
passed a piece of legislation
five days after he became president and
he passed
15 transformative pieces of legislation
in the first hundred days
we are on day like 34 35 and
nothing is passed the reconciliation
bill will eventually become law but it
will become law with no
republican votes and again that's fine
if but it's not
fulfilling that legacy and the urgency
of the action
and the mandate which i believe that
history has handed
it handed it to trump and he [ __ ] it
up right he totally screwed it up he
could have remade america and made us
into the greatest country
ever coming out on the other side of
this he decided not to do that
i think biden was again handed that like
a scepter almost it's like all you have
to do all america wants
is for you to raise it up high yeah but
he's keeping it within the realm of
traditional politics
i think it's a huge mistake why so this
is everything you're saying is makes
perfect sounds like take yeah okay it's
like
it's like again if the aliens showed up
it's like the obvious
thing to do is like what's the popular
thing
like 80 of americans support this
like do that clean
uh also do it like with
like grace where you're able to bring
people together not like
in a political way but like obvious like
obvious common sense way like uh
just people the republicans the
democrats just bring them together on a
policy
and like bold just hammer it without the
dirt
without the mess whatever tried to
compromise just
the yell with have a good twitter
account like
loud very clear we're gonna give a two
thousand dollar
stimulus check anyone who wants a
vaccine guess a vaccine
at scale would make america let's make
america great again
by manufacturing like we are
manufacturing
most of the world's vaccine because
we're bad [ __ ]
yeah and without maybe uh with more
eloquence than that and
and just do that why haven't we seen
that for
many for several presidencies because of
coalitional politics
and they owe something to somebody else
for example
biden has got a lot of the democratic
constituency has to satisfy
within this bill so there's gonna be a
lot of [ __ ] that goes in there state and
local aid
um all this stuff again i'm not even
saying this is bad but he's like
his theory is and this isn't wrong is
like
we're gonna take the really popular
stuff and use it as cover for the more
downwardly
less popular and so the dems could face
the accusation
the people who are on this side this is
their push back to me they're like
why would we give away the most popular
thing in the bill
and then we would never be able to pass
state and local aid right
why would we do that and the republicans
are the same thing right like
mitch mcconnell because he's a [ __ ]
idiot decided to say
we're gonna pair these two thousand
dollar stimulus checks with like section
230 repeal
it was like oh it's obviously dead right
like it's not gonna happen
together that's largely why i believe
trump lost the election
and why those races down in georgia went
the way that they did obviously trump
had something to do with it but the
reason why is
they have long-standing things that
they've wanted to get done and in the
words of rahm emanuel never let a good
crisis go to waste
and try and get as much as you possibly
can done within a single bill
my counter would be this things have
worked this way for too long
which is that the reconciliation bill is
almost certainly
going to be the only large signature
legislative accomplishment of the biden
presidency that's just how american
politics works
maybe he gets one more maybe one he gets
a second reconciliation bill
then you're running for midterms it's
over i believe
that by trying to change the paradigm of
our politics
leaning into exactly what i'm talking
here you could possibly transcend that
to a new one and i'm not naive i think
people respond
to political pressures and the way that
we found this out
was david perdue who was just a total
corporate you know dollar jor dollar
general ceo guy
he was against the original 1200
stimulus checks
but then trump came out who's the single
most popular figure in the republican
party
he's like i want two thousand dollar
stimulus checks and all of a sudden
purdue running in georgia is like yeah
i'm with president trump i want a 2
000 stimulus check that was if you're an
astute observer of politics to say
you can see there that you can force
people to do the right thing
because it's the popular thing and that
if it's clean
if you don't give them any other excuse
they have to do it
yeah so this is this is what we've been
gaslit into our culture war framework of
politics
and the reason it feels so broken and
awful
is because it is but there is a way out
it's just that nobody wants to be it's a
game of chicken right because maybe it
is true maybe we would never be able to
get
your other democratic priorities or
republican priorities but i think that
the country understands
that this is [ __ ] terrible and would
be willing to support somebody who does
it differently
there's just a lot of disincentives to
not stay without
there's a lot of incentives to not stray
from the traditional path
yeah is it also possible that
the a students are not participating
like we drove all the the superstars
away from politics
so like you just had this argument
before i mean everything you're saying
sort of uh rings
true like this is the obvious thing to
do
as a student of history you can almost
like tell like
if you look at great people in history
this is what great leaders in history
this is what they did
it's like uh clean bold
action uh sometimes facing crisis but
we're facing a crisis no we're in a
christ
so why don't we uh
uh why don't we see those leaders step
up that's i mean
you say that's kind of like it makes
sense there's a lot of different
interests to play
you don't want to risk too many things
so on so forth but that's what like
that sounds like the c students i don't
think it's that
i think it's that the pipeline of
politician creation
is just totally broken from beginning to
end
so it's not that ace students don't want
to be
uh politicians it's basically the way
that our
current primary system is constructed is
what is the greatest threat to you as a
member of congress
it's not losing your reelection
it's losing your primary right so that
means especially in a safe
district you're most concerned about
being hit if you're a republican from
the right
if you're a democrat from the left for
not being a good enough one
that's actually what stops people more
heterodox people in particular
from winning primaries because the
people who vote in our primaries
are the party faithful that's how you
get the production
the production it's important to
understand the production pipeline which
is that
all right i'm from texas so that's what
i know best so it's like if you think in
texas
if you're a more heterodox like state
legislature
or something who's real works with the
left on this and does that
you're going to get your ass beat in a
republican primary because they're going
to be like he worked with the left to do
this blah blah take it out of context
and you're screwed
and then that means you never ascend up
the next level of the ladder
and then so on and so forth all the way
but i do think
trump changed everything this is why i
have some hope which is that
he showed me that all the people i
listened to
were totally wrong about politics and
that's the most valuable lesson you
could ever teach me
which was i was like wait i don't have
to listen to these people
they don't know anything actually you
know yeah that's that's powerful man
like he did it that's exceptionally
powerful this guy even if he didn't
do anything with it it doesn't matter
right
he showed that it's possible exactly and
that
that means uh that means a lot that
means
you're absolutely right there's young
people right now that kind of look
turn around like huh you're like wait i
don't have to comb my hair a certain way
yeah
and go to law school and be an [ __ ]
who everybody knows is an [ __ ] yeah
and and then get elected to state
legislature i mean look
who's the number one person in the new
york prime or new york city
uh primary right now andrew yang he's
polling
higher than everybody else in the race i
look maybe the polls are totally [ __ ]
and maybe he'll lose because of ranked
choice voting and all that but i
consider andrew i mean i know him a
little bit and i've you know followed
his candidacy from the very beginning
i consider him an inspiration he's the
new
generation of politics like if i see
who's going to be president
20 years from now it's going to be i'm
not saying it's going to be andrew yang
i think it'll be somebody
like andrew yang outside the political
system who talks in a totally different
way
right just a completely one of my
favorite things that he said on the
debate stage he's like
look at us we're all wearing makeup it's
cr you know yeah
he like he like brought that that he
brought that and he's writing like yeah
why are they're all wearing makeup he
probably arguably hasn't gone far enough
almost
yes uh but he showed that as possible
and then
you you see other like aoc is a good
example of somebody at least in my
opinion
is doing the same kind of thing but
going too far
in like well i don't know she's doing
the trump thing but on the other side so
i don't know
what's too far don't know judgment of it
yeah i will tell you the future of
politics
appreciate the art of it right no i do
look i don't i'm not a big aoc
fan but she's a genius media genius once
in a generation talent
the way that she uses social media
instagram and everybody on the right is
like trying to copy her like matt gates
like i want to be the
conservative aoc i'm like it's just not
gonna happen dude like it you just don't
have it like what she has it's like it's
electric
and trump had that like i've been to a
trump rally
like to cover as a journalist there's
nothing like it
in america and yang is similar it's the
same way where you're like there is
something going on here
which is just like i've been to an obama
rally i've been to a clinton rally
i've been to um several normal politics
that's fine you know with trump and with
yang
it was it's another world yeah it's
another world yeah
there's there's probably thousands of
people listening right now who are just
like doing a
yes slow clap yes i know i know
uh yang gang uh forever okay but uh
yeah i mean my worst fear i i prefer
yeah uh
uh andrew yang kind of
free uh improvisational
idea exchange all that versus aoc
who i think no matter what she stands
for
is a drama machine creates dramas just
like trump does i would say my worst
fear
would be in 2024 is aoc old enough
it'd be aoc versus trump i don't think
she's old enough i think you'd have to
be
i think she's 30 so she needs five more
years so probably not
yeah okay but that kind of yeah that
that's or trump jr well aoc probably
wouldn't win a democratic primary so i
mean look joe biden is
you know that's pretty much showed that
that's exactly what you're saying yeah
this process grooms you
over time it's you see the same thing in
academia actually which is very
interesting
is the the process of getting tenure
there's this
it's like you're being taught
without explicitly being taught yes
to behave in the way that everybody's
behaved before
i've heard this it was funny i've had a
few conversations
that um were deeply disappointing
which which are which involved
statements like
this is what's good for your career yes
this kind of conversation almost like
mentor to mentee conversation
or it's you know it's like there's a
grooming process in the same way i guess
you're saying the primary process
does the same kind of thing so i mean
that's what people have talked about
with andre
yang it was uh it was he was being
suppressed by a bunch of different
forces the mainstream media and all
just the democratic just that whole
process didn't
didn't like the the honesty that he was
showing right for now but here's my
question to you
people got to see look jordan peterson
is one of the most famous people in
america
right like you have a massive podcast
you're more famous than half the
99 of the people at mit so like
from that perspective everything has
changed and
somewhere out there there's a student
who's taking notice
and i've noticed that with my own career
everybody thought i was crazy for doing
the show with crystal
the hill they thought it was nuts
they're like what are you doing you're a
white house correspondent you've got a
job
forever the other job offer i had was
being a white house correspondent
and people thought i was nuts for not
just sticking there
and you know aging out within washington
pining for appearances on fox news and
cnn and
msnbc but i hated it i just hated doing
it and i did not want to be a company
man like a washington man who's one of
those guys
who like brags to his friends about how
many times he's been on fox
or whatever mostly because i just have a
rebellious streak and i hate being at
the subject of
other people i created something new
which a lot of people watch
to get their news and i notice that
younger people who are
almost all my audience they don't really
look up to any of the people in
traditional
right they don't they don't go and
they're not coming up and being like how
do i be like jim acosta
you know they're like they're like hey
how did you do what you do and the way
you did it is by bucking the system
yeah so i think that we are at a total
split point and look there will always
be a path for people
because like i don't want people to over
learn this lesson i have people who are
like i'm not going to go to college and
i'm like well
just wait yeah like i'm like just i'm
starting yeah like stop
just like just hold on a second but
there will always be a path for the
institutional
there will that will always be there for
you but now there's something else
now there's another game in town and
that's more appealing to
millions and millions and millions and
millions of people who feel
unserved by the corporate media cnn
and these people possibly who feel
unserved
um in the you know the faculty like if
you are
an up and comer who wants to teach as
many
young people as possible i think you
should be on youtube
right like look at the khan academy guy
that guy created a huge business
so i just think we can be cynical and
like upset about what that system is but
we should also have hope
like i have a lot of hope for what can
be in the future yeah there's a there's
a guy people should check out so
my story is a little bit different
because i basically uh
stepped aside with the dream of being an
entrepreneur
earlier in the pipeline than like a like
a
legitimate like senior faculty would
there's an example somebody
people should check out andrew huberman
from stanford who's a neuroscientist
who's as world-class as it gets in terms
of like
10-year faculty just a really
world-class researcher and now he's
doing youtube
yeah i see him on instagram yeah and
he's great so he switched
so he not just does instagram he now has
a podcast
and he's doing he's changing the nature
of like
i believe that andrew might be the
future of stanford
and for a lot it's funny like he's
basically joe rogan is an inspiration to
andrew
and and to me as well and so those
ripple effects and andrew is an
inspiration
probably just like you're saying to
these young like
25 year olds who are soon to become
faculty if we're just talking about
academia
and the same is probably happening with
with government is
funny enough trump probably is inspiring
a huge number of people who are saying
wait a minute i don't have to play by
the rules exactly and i
have to i can think outside the box here
and
you're right and the institutions we're
seeing are just probably lagging behind
so the optimistic view is the future
is going to be full of exciting new
ideas so andrew young is just kind of
the beginning of this
tip of the iceberg and i hope that
iceberg doesn't
it's not this influencer one of the
things that really
bothers me yeah i've gotten a chance no
i should be careful here i don't wanna i
love
everybody but you know these people who
talk about like
you know how to make your first million
or how to succeed and
and they're so i mean yeah that
that makes me a little bit cynical
about uh i'm worried that the people
that win the game of politics
will be ones that want to win the game
of politics
they already are man and like we
mentioned alc
it's i hope they optimize for the
80 populist thing right like they
optimized
for that badass thing that history will
remember you as the great man or woman
that did this thing
versus how do i maximize engagement
today
and keep growing those numbers the the
influencers
are so i'm so allergic to this man
they keep saying how many followers they
have on the different accounts
and it's like i i don't think they
understand
maybe i don't understand i don't really
care
i think it has destructive psychological
effects
one like thinking about the number like
getting excited your number one from
100 to 101 and being like
and today went out to 105. whoa that's a
big jump that maybe like thinking this
way like i wonder what i did
i'll do that again in this way one it's
uh it creates anxiety almost
psychological effects whatever
the the more important thing is it
prevents you from
truly thinking boldly
in the long arc of history in uh
creatively
thinking outside the box doing huge
actions
and i actually up my optimism is in the
sense that
that kind of action will beat out all
the influencers
well i don't know lex this is where my
cynicism comes
in so there's a guy madison cawthorne
the youngest member
of congress um and he
i don't want to say god caught but there
was like an email where he was like
my staff is only oriented around comms
like he was basically saying he got
basically like
my staff is only uh centered on
communications and that's the right play
if you do want to get the benefits of
our current electoral political
and engagement system which is that
what's the best way to be known
within the right as a as a right-wing
politician it's to be
a culture warrior go on ben shapiro's
podcast
be one of the people on fox news go on
sean hannity's show go on tucker's show
and all that because you become a mini
celebrity
within that world left unsaid is that
that world is increasingly shrinking
portion of the american population
and they barely they can't even win a
popular vote election
um let alone barely win and eek out an
electoral college victory
in 2016. well but the incentives are all
aligned within that
and it's the same thing really on the
left but you're right which is that
ultimate look this is this is why
geniuses are geniuses because they buck
the short-term incentives they focus on
the long-term
they bet big and they usually fail but
then when they get
big they uh succeed spectacularly yeah
the people i know who have done this the
best are like
a lot of the crypto folks that i've
spoken to like
some of the stuff they say i'm like i
don't know if that's going to happen but
look they're like billionaires right
yeah and you're like so they were wrong
the way i've heard it expressed is
you can be wrong a lot but when you're
right you get right
big and i mean i've seen this on my
career i mean he
took spectacular risk like spectacular
risk and just double down double down
double down double down double down
and you can kind of tell to him i mean
you know him better than i do but like
for my observation i don't think the
money matters
as right i just i like when i see him
i'm like i don't it's
nobody works as hard as you do and
builds the way that you build
if it's just about the money it just it
just doesn't happen like
nobody wills spacex into existence
just for the money like it's not worth
it frankly right like he probably
destroyed years of his life and like
mental sanity money or attention or fame
none of that yeah
that's not the primary priority well
that's what's so appealing to me to me
in particular about him just like in how
he built like i read a biography of him
and just like the way that he
constructed his life and like is
able to hyper focus and meeting after
meeting and drill down
and also hire all the right people who
execute
each one of his tasks discreetly to his
perfection
is amazing like that's actually the mark
of a good leader
but i mean if you think about his career
the reason he's a renegade is because
probably he was told to like put it in
an index fund or whatever like whenever
he made his like 29 million
and from paypal i don't know how much he
made and then just go along that run
he's like no
so he you know succeeds spectacularly so
you have to have somebody
who's willing to come in and buck that
system so for
for for now i think our politics are
generally frozen i think that
that model is going to be most generally
appealing
to the mean person but somebody will
come along and we'll change everything
yeah i'm just surprised there's not more
of them
yeah on on that topic uh it's now
20 what is it 21 yes let's
let's make some predictions he can be
wrong about good what major
political people are you thinking will
run in 2024
including trump junior senior mm-hmm
or ivanka i don't know
any trump trump uh
and uh who do you think wins i think joe
biden
will run again in 2024 and i think he
will run against someone with the last
name trump i do not know whether that
is trump or trump jr uh but i think one
of those people
will probably be the gop nominee in
2024. who was it
some prominent political figure was it
romney somebody like that
said that trump will win the primary if
he runs again of course
that's not even a question trump is the
single most popular figure
in the republican party by orders of max
oh i mean probably more honestly there
was a actually i can tell you because i
saw the data
which is that pre-january 6th it was
like 54
of republicans wanted him to run again
then it went down
eight points after january six two days
later
and then after impeachment it went right
back up to 54
so the exact same number is in
february at post impeachment vote as it
was after
november now look yeah again surveys
[ __ ] etc but like
that's all the data we have that's what
i can point to if trump runs he will be
the nominee
and he will be he will be the 2024
nominee
i just don't know if he wants to it it
really depends like
do you think he wins after the trump
vaccine
heals all of us do you think trump wins
it depends on how popular culture
functions over the next four years and i
can tell you that they are
because i don't think biden has that
much to do with it because again
trump is not a manifestation of an
affirmative policy action
it is a defensive wall
against cultural liberalism at its best
so it's like this is why it doesn't
matter what biden does
if there are more riots if there is
a more sense of persecution amongst
people who are more lean towards
conservative or like hey
i don't know about that that's crazy
then he
very well could win let's okay let's say
joe biden doesn't run and they put up
like kamala harris i think he would i
think he would beat her
and i i don't think there's a question
that trump would beat kamala harris in
2024.
and you don't think anybody else i don't
know how the the process works you don't
think anybody else on the democratic
side can uh
take the well how could you run against
the sitting vice president
you know it's like if joe joe biden has
a 98 approval rating
in the democratic party if he says she
is my heir
i think enough people will listen to him
in a competitive primary
or a non-competitive primary and then
there's all these things about how
primary systems themselves are rigged
the dnc could make it known
that they'll blacklist anybody who does
try and primary kamala harris
um and look i mean progressives aren't
necessarily all that popular
amongst actual democrats like we found
that out um during the election
there's an entire constituency which
loves joe biden and joe biden level
politics
and so if he tells them to vote for
kamala i think i think she would
probably get it
but again there's a lot of game theory
obviously happening but
see i think you're talking about
everything you're saying is
correct about mediocre candidates it
feels like
if there's somebody like a really strong
i don't want to use this term
incorrectly but populist
somebody that speaks to the the 80
that's is able to provide
bold eloquently described
solutions that are popular i think that
breaks through all of this nonsense
how how do they break through the
primary system because the problem is
the primary system is not populism
it's primaries so it's like but you
don't think they can tweet
their way to well you have to be willing
to win a gop primary
you basically have to be at whoever wins
the gop primary in my opinion will be
the person most hated by the left
one of the people things that people
forget is you know who came in second to
trump
ted cruz and the reason why is because
ted cruz was the second most hated guy
by liberals in america a second to trump
they have nothing in policy in common
but don't you think this kind of
brilliantly described system of hate
being the
the main mechanism of our electoral
choices yeah
don't you think that just has to do with
mediocre candidates like
it like it's basically the field of
candidates including trump including
everybody
was just like didn't make anyone feel
great right
it's like really this is what we have to
choose from
maybe a mark cuban or like
uh mark cuban is a democrat or
it would have to be somebody like that
somebody who because here's the thing
about trump it's not just that it was
trump
he was so [ __ ] famous like people
don't realize he was so
famous like i even when i first met
trump i met
a couple of other presidents but when i
met trump even i felt like
kind of star struck because i was like
yo this is the guy from the apprentice
yeah i'm like this is the dude yeah
like because i'm like my dad and i used
to sit and watch the apprentice when i
was in high school and then one of the
guys was from college station where i
grew up and were like oh my god like
that guy's on the apprentice like it was
a phenomenon there's like that level
it's kind of like when i met joe rogan
i'm like holy [ __ ] that's yeah
that's i don't feel that way when i meet
mitt romney or tom cotton or josh hall i
met all of them
um but there's a lot of celebrities
right do you think there's some
celebrities we're not even thinking
about that could step
in the rock so i was about to say i
think the rock could do it but
does he want to do it i mean it's
terrible like it's terrible gig
it's very hard to do i don't know if the
rock necessarily has like
the formed policy agenda because then
here's the other problem what what if we
set ourselves up for a system where like
these people keep winning but like with
trump they have no idea how to run a
government
it's actually really hard right and you
have to have the know-how and the trust
to find the right people this is this is
where the genius
element comes in is you have to
understand that front
and you have to understand how to
execute discrete tasks like
this is the fdr this is why it's so hard
like
fdr lincoln tr they were who they were
and they live in history and
their name rings like for a reason and
yeah i mean one of the most depressing
lessons i got from 2020
is it almost it seems like in my opinion
that we over learn the lesson of our
success and not of our failures
for example like we have this narrative
in our head
that we always have the right person at
the right time
during crisis and in some cases it was
true we didn't deserve lincoln
we didn't deserve fdr we didn't deserve
we didn't deserve a lot of presidents at
times of crisis
but then you're like okay george w bush
911
that was terrible um reconstruction
andrew johnson
awful right like we had several periods
in our history
where the crisis was there they they
were called
and they did not show up and i really it
hadn't happened
in my lifetime except for 911 and even
then you could kind of see
that as an opportunity for somebody like
obama to come in and fix it
but then he didn't do it and then trump
didn't do it
and you realize i feel like our politics
are most analogous
to like the 1910s like all
in terms of the gilded age in terms of
that remember there's that long period
of
presence between um between
like lincoln and teddy roosevelt we were
like wait like
who's president like or or even in even
tr was like an exception where you'll
have like
calvin coolidge who like silent cow so
we're living through
over cleveland that's kind of how i if i
think of us within history
i feel like we're in one of those times
we're just waiting
it feels really important to us right
now like this is the most important
moment in history but it might be
could just be a blip right 20 30 year
blip like when you think about
who was president between 1890 and 19
before i mean
yeah between like 1888 and 1910
like nobody really thinks about that
period of america but like that was an
entire lifetime for people
right like what did they how did they
feel about the country that they were in
that's hilarious
that's how i kind of think about where
we are funny to think i mean i don't
want to minimize it but like we haven't
really gone through uh a world war ii
style crisis so like
say that there is a crisis in like
several decades
of that level right existential risks
to a large portion of the world
then what will be remembered is world
war ii
maybe a little bit about vietnam and
then whatever that crisis is
and this whole period that we see as
dramatic even coronavirus
even 911 even 911
it's like because you can look at how
many people died and all those kinds of
things all the drama around
the war on terror and all those kinds of
things
maybe obama will be remembered for being
the first african-american president
but then like that's yeah that's
fascinating to think about
oh man even trump will be like oh
okay that guy yeah like maybe he'd be
remembered as
the first uh celebrity
i mean reagan was already a governor
right yeah so
so like the first a political celebrity
that was a
so maybe if there's more celebrities in
the future
they'll say that trump was the first
person to pave the
the way for celebrities to win oh man
yeah
and uh yeah i still i still hold that
this this era will probably be
remembered
the you know people say i talk about
elon way too much but
but the reality is like there's not many
people that are doing the kind of things
he's doing is why
i talk about is i think this era it's
not necessarily elon and spacex but this
error will be remembered by
the new the like of the space
exploration
of uh the commercial of companies
getting into space exploration
of space travel and perhaps
perhaps like artificial intelligence
around social media all those kinds of
things
this might be remembered for that but
every all the political bickering all
that nonsense
that might might be very well forgotten
one way to think about it
is that the internet is so young
yeah i think about it um so jeff jarvis
he's a media scholar i respect
he's not the only person to say this but
many others have which is that look this
is kind of like the printing press
there was a whole 30 years war because
of the printing press yeah
it took a long time for [ __ ] to sort out
i think that's where we're at with the
internet like at a certain level it
disrupts
everything and that's a good thing it
can be very tumultuous
um i never felt like i was living
through history until corona paris like
you know
like until we were all locked down i was
like i'm living through history
like this there's this very overused
cliche in dc
where every com staffer wants you to
think that what their boss just did
is history and i've always been like
this isn't history this is some like
stupid [ __ ] bill
you know whatever but like that was the
first time i was like this
is history like this yeah right here
well i was hoping
uh tragedy aside that this i wish the
primaries happened during coronavirus
so that we because like then we can see
so okay here's a bunch of people facing
crisis
and it's an opportunity for leaders to
step up like
i still believe the optimistic view is
uh
the game theory of like influencers
will always be defeated by actual great
leaders
so like maybe the great leaders are rare
but i think they're sufficiently
out there that they will step up
especially in the moments of crisis
and coronavirus is is obviously a crisis
where like
you know mass manufacture of tests uh
all kinds of infrastructure building
that you could have done in 2020
there's so many possibilities for just
like bold action
and sad uh none of that
even just forget actually doing the
action
advocating for it yeah just saying like
this we need we need to do this
and none of that like the speeches that
biden made
i don't even remember a single speech
that bad made
because there's zero bold i mean their
strategy was to be quiet
and let donald trump uh polarize the
electorate
polarized electorate and hope that
results in
in uh them winning uh because of the
high unemployment numbers and all those
kinds of things
as opposed to like let's go big let's go
with a big speech
like you know that ah
yeah it's a loss lost opportunities in
some sense
so we talked a bunch about politics but
one of the other interesting things is
that you're involved with is uh
or involved with defining the future of
is journalism
i suppose you can think of podcasts as a
kind of journalism
but also just writing in general just
whatever the hell the future of this
thing looks like
uh is up to be defined by people like
you
so what do you think is broken about
journalism and what do you think is the
future of journalism
i think the future of journalism looks
much more like
what we and i are doing here right now
and
journalism is going to be downstream
from a culture that can be a good and a
bad thing depending on how you look at
it
we are going to look at our media our
media is going to look
much more like it did pre-mass media
and the way that i mean that is that
back in the 18
um in the 1800s in particular
especially after the invention of the
telegraph when information itself was
known so for example like
you and i don't need to let's say you
and i are competing journalists
you and i are no longer competing quote
unquote
to tell the public x event happened
all journalism today is largely
explaining why did x happen
and part of the problem with that is
that
that means that it's all up for partisan
interpretation
now you can say that that's a bad thing
i think it's a great thing
because the highest level of literacy
and
news viewership in america was during
the time of yellow journalism
it was during the time of partisan
journalism not a surprise
people like to really read the news from
people that they agree with
you could say that's bad echo chambers
etc
that's the downside of it the upside is
more people are more educated
more people are interested in the news
so i think the proliferation of mass
media i mean sorry of this format
of long form of not just long form
dude i do i do updates on instagram
which are five minutes oh you consider
like
instagram yeah almost even twitter oh of
course twitter
twitter is where i get my news from i
don't read the paper i have literally
twitter is my news aggregator it's
called my wire where i find out about
hard events like the president has
departed the white house
but not only like that i don't know
about you but for i also looked at
twitter
to the exact thing you're saying which
is the response to the news right
the thoughtful sounds ridiculous but you
can be pretty thoughtful in a single
tweet if you fi
if you follow the right people yeah you
can get that and so
that is the future of media which is
that the future of media
is it will be much smaller amount
or much larger amounts of people which
are famous to smaller groups
so walter cronkite's never gonna happen
again at least in our
probably within our lifetimes where
everybody in america know who's this guy
is
that that age is over i think that's a
good thing because
now people are going to get the news
from the people that they trust
yes some of it will be opinionated i'm
going to my my program
i'm crystal and i are like we are this
she's coming from this like view i'm
coming from this view
that's our bias when we talk about
information and we're going to talk
about the information
that we think is important and it has
garnered a large audience
i think that's very much where the
future is going to be
and the reason why i think that's a good
thing is because
people will be engaged more within it
rather than the current system
where news is highly concentrated highly
consolidated
has group think has the same elite
production pipeline problem of
everybody knows journalists all come
from the same socioeconomic background
and they all party together here in dc
or in new york or in la
or wherever and there's part of the same
mono culture and that affects what they
uh that affects what they report this
will cause a total dispersion
of all of that the the a the battle of
our age
is going to be the guild versus the
non-guild so
like what we see right now with the new
york times and clubhouse
this is a very very very very very
intentional
thing that is happening which is that
the times
talking about unfettered conversations
that's
happening on clubhouse for people who
aren't aware this is important because
they need to be the fetterers of
conversation
they need to be the inter-agent that's
where they get their power they get
their power
from convincing facebook that they are
the ones who can
check stuff they are the ones who can
tell you whether something is right
or wrong that battle over
unimpeded conversation and the explosion
of a format that you and i are doing
really well in
and then this more consolidated one
which holds cultural power
and elite power and more importantly
money right over you and i
that's the battle that we're all gonna
do do you think unfettered conversations
have a chance to win this battle
yes i do in the long run in the long run
the internet is simply too powerful
but here's the mistake everybody makes
the new york times will never lose
it will just become one of us see you
think so they already are
they are the largest daily the daily
look at the daily
not even that think about it not in
podcasting the times
is not a mass media product it
is a subscription product for upper
middle class
largely white liberals who live the same
circumstances
across the united states and in europe
there's nothing wrong with that
but here's the thing you can't be the
paper of record when you're actually
the paper of upper middle class white
america your job is to report on the
news
from that angle and deliver them the
product that they want
there's nothing wrong with that their
stock price is higher than ever
they're making 10 times more money than
they did 10 years ago
but it comes at the cost of not having a
mass
application audience so like when people
i think people in our space
are always like the new york times going
to be destroyed no it's actually even
better
they will just become one of us they
already are their subscription platform
well yes in terms of the actual
mechanism but you know
new york times is still and i don't
think i'm speaking about a particular
sector i think it
as a brand it is it does have the
level of credibility assigned to it
still you know there's
politization of it totally but
if there's a credibility like it has
much more credibility than
i forgive me but then i think you and i
have
no you're right in in terms of uh your
podcast like people are not going to be
like
uh they're going to cite the new york
times versus what you said on the
podcast
for uh for an opinion
that i wonder in the sense of battles
whether unfettered conversations whether
joe rogan whether
your podcast can become the
have at the same level of legitimacy or
the the flip side
new york times loses the legitimacy to
be at the same level
of uh in terms of how we talk about it
it's getting long it's a long battle
right it's going to take a long time and
i'm saying this is where i think the end
state is going
and look at what the times is doing
they're leaning into podcasting for a
reason
but not just podcasting as in
npr level like here's what's happening
michael barbaro is a [ __ ] celebrity
right the guy who does the daily yeah
that guy's famous
amongst these people because they're
like oh my god i love michael like i
love the way he does this stuff
again that's fine more people are
listening to the news i think that's a
good thing
yeah and then who else do they hire ezra
klein from vox
yeah kara swisher also from box who does
pivot which is an amazing podcast
um or uh jane coston same thing it's
personalities who are becoming
bundled together within this brand right
here's yeah okay maybe i'm just a hater
[Laughter]
because i loved podcasting from the
beginning i loved green day before they
were cool man
but i am bothered by it like why doesn't
karis wish her she's done successfully i
think i know oh no she was always a part
of some kind of institution i'm not sure
but she started her own thing i think it
would
i don't know if that's her own thing
yeah yeah so she she was very successful
there why the hell
did she join the new york times with the
new podcast why is michael barbaro not
do his
own thing because he gets paid and
because he has he wants the elite cachet
that you just referenced within his
social circle in new york
which is that i think the biggest
mistake that some of the venture people
make is
if we give everybody the tools that
those people are all going to leave to
like go sub sack and go independent
within their social circle sacrificing
some money from being independent is
worth it to be a part of the new york
times
that's sad to me because it propagates
old thinking like you know it propagates
old institutions
and you could say that new york times is
going to evolve quickly and so on but
i would love it if there was a mechanism
for re-establishing like for building
new new york times
in terms of public legitimacy and i
suppose that's uh wishful thinking
because
it takes time to build trust in
institutions and it takes time to build
new institutions my main thing i would
say is public legitimacy as a concept
it's not going to be there in mass media
anymore
because of the balkanization of
audiences i mean think about it right
like
um this is like legion you know the
classic stuff around a thousand true
fans or
no sorry like 100 true fans even now
like you can make a living on the
internet just talking to a hundred
people
yeah if as long as they're all high
frequency traders some of the highest
people
pay people on sub stack they don't have
that many subs
it's just that they're wall street guys
right so people pay a lot of money again
that's great so what you will have is an
increasing
balkanization of the internet um of
audiences and of niches
people will become increasingly famous
within us you will become
astoundingly famous i'm sure you've
noticed this with your fan base i
certainly have with mine like 99 of
people have no idea who i am
but when somebody meet they're like oh
my god i watch your show
every day right looks the only thing
watching for news right like instead of
casually famous
if that makes sense like oh yeah that's
like alec baldwin yeah you know yeah oh
[ __ ] that's solid ball but you're not
like oh [ __ ]
i love you alec baldwin it's this is a
ben smith
of the new york times actually he wrote
this column he's like the future is
everybody will be famous
but only to a small group of people and
i think that is true
but again i don't decry it i think it's
great because i think that the more
that that happens the more engaged
people will be and it empowers
different voices to be able to come in
and then possibly i wouldn't say destroy
but compete
against i mean look at joe joe is more
powerful
than cnn and msnbc and fox
all put together that gives me like
immense inspiration
yeah like he created the space for me to
succeed and i told him that when i met
him i was like
dude like i listened to his podcast when
i was like young and like
and i remember like when i got to meet
him and all that and i told him this
on this pod i was like i didn't know
people were millions
were willing to listen to a guy talk
about chimps for three straight hours
including me i didn't know that yeah
he's one of those people yeah me too i
learned something about myself okay
yeah and so by creating that space i'd
be like wait
there's a hunger here like he showed us
all the way
and none of us will ever again be as
famous as rogan because he was the first
and that's fine because he created the
umbrella ecosystem for us all to thrive
that is where i see like a great amount
of hope
within that story yeah and the cool
thing he also supports that ecosystem
he's such a
he's so so generous one of the things he
paved the way on for me
is to to show that you can just be
honest
publicly honest yes and uh
not jealous of other people's success
but instead of being supportive and
and all those kinds of things just like
loving towards others he's been an
inspiration
i mean uh to the comics community
i think there are a bunch of uh before
that
i think there were all a bunch of
competitive haters towards each other
yeah and now he's like
just injected love yeah you know they're
like they're still like many are still
resistant but they're like they can't
help it because he's such a huge voice
he like forces them to be like loving
towards each other and the same
i tried to one of the reasons i wanted
to start this
podcast was to try to enj
i wanted to be like a uh do what joe
rogan did
but for the scientific community like my
little circle scientific community of
like
like let's support each other yeah well
like avi loeb
i would have no idea who he was if it
wasn't for you i mean i assume you put
him in touch with joe
he went on joe's show i had him on my
show like millions of people would have
no idea who he was if it wasn't for you
just by the way in terms of
deep state of government avilo has to do
with aliens you better believe joe
dude the last thing i sent to him was
the american airlines audio
did you see that uh the pilots who were
oh my god dude this is amazing so like
this american airlines flight crew was
over new mexico this happened five or
six days ago
and they the guy comes and goes hey do
you have any targets up here
a large cylindrical object just flew
over me
oh so this happens so this happens yes
then
a guy or like a radio catcher records
this and posts it online
american airlines confirms that this is
authentic audio
and they go all further questions should
we refer to the fbi
so then okay american airlines just
confirmed it's a legitimate transmission
fbi then the faa comes out and says
we were tracking no objects
in the vicinity of this plane at the
time of the transmission
so the only plausible explanation that
online salutes have been able to say is
maybe he saw a learjet which was
you know using like open source data faa
rules that out
so what was it he saw a large
cylindrical object
while he was mid-flight american
airlines but you can go
online listen to the audio yourself this
is a 100
no [ __ ] transmission confirmed by
american airlines
of a commercial pilot over new mexico
seeing a quote-unquote large cylindrical
object
in the air like i said um when you first
start talking i've never believed
i've never believed more in ufos and
aliens yeah yeah
this is awesome yeah i i i just wish
both the american airlines
uh fbi and uh government would be more
transparent like there would be voices
i know it sounds ridiculous but the kind
of transparency do you see maybe not joe
rogan
he's like overly transparent he's just a
comic really but
just uh i don't know like a podcast from
the fbi
just like being honest like excited
confused
uh i'm sure the car
they're being overly cautious about the
release information i'm sure there's a
lot of information that would inspire
the public
that will inspire trust in institutions
that will not damage
national security like it seems to me
obvious and the reason they're not
sharing it is because of this
momentum of bureaucracy of caution and
so on but there's probably so much cool
information
that the government has the way i almost
i wouldn't say it confirmed it's real
but trump didn't didn't declassify it
like you know that if there was ever a
president that actually wanted to get to
the bottom of it it was him
yeah i mean he didn't declassify it man
and
people begged him to i know for a fact
because i pushed
to try and make this happen that some
people did speak to him about it
and he was like no i'm not gonna do it
so he might be afraid
uh that's what i mean though he's a they
were probably all telling him they're
like sir you can't do this you know all
this like wow and and i get that and
there's this legislation written in
coveted that like they have six months
to release it
is that real what is that that was a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] i think it's
both
there's so many different levels of
classification that people
need to understand i mean look i read
john podesta he was the
chief of staff to bill clinton he's a
big ufo guy he he
tried like him and clinton tried to get
some of this information and they could
not get
any of it and they were talking about
the president and the white house chief
of staff
well there's a whole bureaucracy bill
just like you're saying with intent you
have to be
like that has to be your focus because
there's a whole bureaucracy built around
secrecy
for probably for a good reason so to get
through to the information
there's a whole like paperwork process
all that kind of stuff you can't just
walk in and get the
unless again with intention that becomes
your thing like exactly
let's revolutionize this thing and then
you get
only so many things that it's it's sad
that the the bureaucracy
has gotten so bulky um but i think
the hopeful messages from earlier in our
conversation it seems like
a single person can't fix it but if you
hire the right team
it feels like you can can't fix
everything i don't want to i don't want
to give people on real estate
expectations
you can fix a lot especially in crisis
you can remake america
yeah and the reason i know that is
because it's already happened twice
fdr or in modern history fdr
and jfk sorry fdr and jfk's
assassination
lbj two hyper-competent men
who understood government who understood
personnel and coincidentally were
friends i love this i don't think
actually people
understand this fdr met johnson
three days after he won his congress
his election to congress special
election he was only 29 years old
and he left that meeting and called
somebody and said
this young man is gonna be president of
the united states someday like
even then like what was within him to
understand and to recognize that
and sometimes johnson as a young member
of congress would come and have
breakfast with fdr like just to the
great
political minds of the 20th century just
sitting there talking like i would give
anything
to know what that was happening i hope
they were real with each other and there
was like a genuine human connection
right that
i that seemed like johnson wasn't a
genuine guy
i need to read those thousands of pages
uh i've been way too focused on hitler
i was gonna say one of my goals in
coming to this is i was like i gotta get
lex into two things because i know he'll
love it
i know he'll love lbj if he's it has to
take the time to read the books
100 he's the most of all the presidents
i didn't say you'll love him but you'll
love the books about him because the
books are a story of america
the story of politics the story of power
this is the guy who wrote the power
broker
these books are up there with decline
and fall of the roman empire
by edward gibbon in terms of how power
works study of power
exactly that's no that's why carol wrote
the books
and that's why the books are not really
about lbj they're about power in
washington
and about the consolidation of power
post new deal the consolidation then
or the using the levers of power like
johnson knew in order to
change the house of representatives the
senate of the united states
and ultimately the presidency of the
united states which ended in failure and
disaster with vietnam don't get me wrong
but he's overlooked for so many of the
incredible things that he did with civil
rights nobody else could have done it no
no one else could have gotten it done
and the second thing is
we gotta get you into world war one we
gotta get you more
into world war one because i think
that's a rabbit hole which i know you're
a dan carlin fan
so blueprint for armageddon yeah
guaranteed
but but there's fewer evil people there
yes but well but that's what actually
there's a banality of that evil of the
kaiser
and of the uh austro-hungarians
and of see i like world war one more
because it was unresolved
it's one of those periods i was talking
to you about about like sometimes you're
called and you fail
like that's what happened i mean 50
million people were killed
in the most horrific way like people
literally drowned in the mud
like like an entire generation one stat
i love
is that you know britain didn't need a
draft till
1916. like they went two
years of throwing people into barbed
wire voluntarily
yeah and because people love their
country and they love the king
and they thought they were going against
the kaiser it's just like
that conflict to me i just can't read
enough about it
also just like births russian revolution
you know
yeah i mean hitler you can't talk about
world war ii without world war one right
right
and i'm obsessed with the conflict i've
read way too many books about it for
this reason is it's
unresolved and like the the roots of so
much of even our current problems
are happening in versailles right like
vietnam is
because of the treaty of versailles um
many ways the middle eastern problems
and the division of the states there
the treaty of versailles in terms of the
penalties against
germany but also the uh fallout from
those wars on the french
and the german population french and the
british populations and their reluctance
for war in 1939 or 1938
when when neville chamberlain goes right
like that's one of the things people
don't understand is the actual appetite
of the british public
at that time they didn't want to go to
war only churchill he was the only one
in the
you know in the gathering storm right
like being like hey this is really bad
and all of that and then even in the
united states our streak of isolationism
which
swept i mean things were because of that
conflict
we were convinced as a country that we
wanted
nothing to do with europe and its
problems and in many ways that
contributed to
the proliferation of hitler and more so
like i'm obsessed with world war one for
this reason
which is that it's just like the root oh
it's like the culmination
of the monarchies then the fall and then
just all the [ __ ] spills out
so from there for like a hundred years
so world war one is like the most
important shift in human history
world war ii is like a consequence of
that yeah it's so so i have a degree in
security studies from georgetown and one
of the thing is that we would focus a
lot on that is like war
and but also like the complexity around
war
and it's funny we never spent that much
time on world war
ii because there's actually quite a
clean war it's a very atypical war
as in the war object which we learned
from world war one
is we must inflict suffering on the
german people
and invade the borders of germany and
destroy hitler
like the center of gravity is the nazi
regime and hitler
so it had a very basic begin and end
begin liberate france invade germany
destroy hitler reoccupy rebuild
world war one what are you fighting for
like
are you i mean and nobody even knew you
can go the german general staff they
were like
even in 1917 they're like the war was
worth it because now we have luxembourg
i'm like really like you killed two
million of your citizens for [ __ ]
luxembourg
and like half of belgium which is now
like a pond yeah and same thing
the french are like well the french more
so they're defending their borders but
like
what are the british fighting for why
did hundreds of thousands of british
people die
in order to preserve the balance of
power in europe and prevent the kaiser
from having a port on the english
channel
like really that's why these that's more
what wars are
they become these like atypical
they become these protracted conflicts
with a necessary diplomatic resolution
it's not clean it's very dirty it
usually leads in the outbreak
of another war and another war and
another war in a slow burn of ethnic
conflict
which bubbles up so that's why i look at
that one
even because it's it's more typical of
warfare yeah how it works
exactly yeah it's it's kind of
interesting you're making me realize
uh that uh world war ii is one of the
rare
wars where you can make a strong case
for it's a fight of good versus
war theory obviously like yeah they're
literally slaughtering jews like
you know we have to kill them and
there's one person doing it i mean
there's one person at the core there's
it's
uh yeah that's fascinating and it's
short and there's a clear aggression
it's interesting that dan uh carlin
has been avoiding hitler as well yeah
probably for this reason probably for
this reason yeah i mean
but it's it's complicated too right
because there's a pressure
that guy has his demons i love this so
much
it's so this is the the i don't know if
you feel this pressure
but as a creative he feels the pressure
of being
maybe not necessarily correct
but maybe correct in the in the sense
that
his understanding he gets to the bottom
of uh of why
something happened of what really
happened
did get to the bottom of it before he
can say something publicly about it
and he is uh tortured by that burden i
know it you know he takes so much [ __ ]
from the historical community for no
reason
i think he's the greatest popularizer
quote-unquote of history
and i wish more people in history
understood it that way
he was an inspiration to me i mean i do
some videos sometimes on my instagram
now where i'll like i'll do like a book
tour i'll be like here's my bookshelf of
these presidents and like
here's what i learned from this book in
this book and this and that was very
much like a
a skill i learned from him of being like
as you know as the historian writes you
know you know
i just love the way he talks he's like
in the mud
oh you know he'll be like quote
he he inspires me man yeah he really
does to like learn
more and i've read i bought a lot of
books because of dan carlin he'll be you
know because of this guy because of that
guy
um in terms of you know another thing he
does which nobody else and i'm probably
guilty of this
he focuses on the actual people involved
like he would tell the story
of actual british soldiers in world war
one
and i probably and maybe you're guilty
of this too we over focus
on what was happening in the german
general staff what's happening in the
british general staff and he doesn't
make that mistake
that's why he tells real history yeah
and and make it
gives it a feeling the result is that
there's a feeling you get the feeling of
what it was like to be there exactly
you know you're becoming quickly
becoming more and more popular
speaking about political issues in part
do you feel a burden
like almost like uh the the prison of
your
prior convictions of having to
being popular with a certain kind of
audience and thereby
unable to really think outside the box i
had
i've really struggled with this i came
up in right-wing media
i came up a much more doctrinaire
conservative in my professional life i
wasn't always conservative we can get to
that later
um if you want and i did
feel an immense pressure after jan
after the election by people to say
wanted me to say the election was stolen
and i knew
i had a sizable part of my audience well
here's the benefit
most people know me from rising which is
with crystal and me
that is inherently a left-right program
so it's a large audience so i felt
comfortable and i knew that i could
still
be fine in terms of my numbers whatever
because a lot many people knew me who
were on the left
and if you know my right listeners
abandoned me
so be it i was had the luxury of able to
take that choice
but i still felt an immense amount of
pressure
to say the election was stolen to give
credence to a lot of the stuff that
trump was doing
to downplay january 6th to downplay many
of the republican senators
or justify many of the republican
senators some of whom i know
who objected to the electoral college
certification and who stoked
some of the flames um that have eaten
the republican base
and i just wouldn't do it and that was
hard man
like i feel more politically homeless
right now than i
ever have but i have realized
in the last couple of months that's the
best thing that ever happened to me it's
freedom
it's true freedom i now say i
say exactly what i think and it's not
that i wasn't doing that before
it's maybe um i would avoid certain
topics or like
i would think about things more from a
team perspective of like am i making
sure
that it's it's i'm not saying i didn't
fight it i still i criticized the right
plenty and trump plenty before the
election and more
it's more just like i no longer feel as
if i even have
the illusion of a stake within the game
i'm like i only look at myself
as an outside observer and i will only
call it as i see it
truly and i i was aspiring to that
before
but i i had to have in a way
trump's stopped the steel thing it like
took my shackles off
100 yeah cause i was like no this is
[ __ ] and i'm gonna say it's [ __ ]
and i think it's bad and i think it's
bad for the republican party
and if people in the republican party
don't agree with me on that
that's fine i'm just not gonna be
necessarily like associated with you
anymore
this is probably one of the first
political related politics-related
conversations we've had
uh i mean unless you caught michael
malus who he was great
yeah i he's the funny guy he's not
so much political as he is like burning
down man
he leans too far in anarchy for me yeah
i
i think he's uh there's a place for that
it's it's almost
well first of all he's uh he's working
on a new book which i really appreciate
outside of
he's working on like a big book for a
while which is white pill
he's also working on this like
short little thing which is uh like
anarchist
um handbook or something like that yeah
it's like anarchy for idiots or
something like that
which i think is really yeah
well me being an idiot right and being
curious about anarchy
seems useful so i like those kinds of
books that's russian heritage man yeah
anarchist 101 yeah i mean it's a uh
i find those kinds of things a useful
thought experiment
because uh that's why and then it's it's
frustrating to me when people talk about
communism or socialism
or even capitalism where they can't
enjoy the thought experiment of like
why did uh communism
fail and maybe ask the question of like
are there
is it possible to make communism succeed
or are there good ideas in communism
like i enjoy the thought experiment like
this the the discourse of it like the
the reasoning and like
devil's advocate and all that people
have like seem to not have patience for
that they're like communism bad
red i was obsessed with the question and
still am
i will never be i will never
quench my thirst for russian history
i love that period
of 1890 to 1925.
it's just like it's so [ __ ] crazy
like the autocracy embodied in
zara alexander and then you get this
like weird fail son
nicholas who is kind of a good guy
but also terrible and also russian
autocracy itself is terrible
and then i just became obsessed with the
question of like why did the bolshevik
revolution succeed
because like people in russia didn't
necessarily want bolshevism
people suffered a lot under bolshevism
and it led to stalinism
how did vladimir lenin do it right like
and i became obsessed with that question
and it's still i find it so interesting
which is that
series of accidents of history
incredible boldness by lenin
incredible real politic smart
unpopular decisions made by trotsky and
stalin
and just like the arrogance of the czars
and of the of the russian
like autocracy and just but at the same
time there's all these like cultural
implications of this right in terms of
like how it became hollowed out
post catherine the great and all that i
was obsessed with
talk because russia was an actual
autocracy
and like actually and i'm like it was
there like they didn't even
remove serfdom to like the civil war in
america like that's
crazy like you know and nobody really
talks about it
and i just beca yeah i was like was
bolshevism
a natural reaction to the excesses of
tsarism
there is a convenient explanation where
that is true
but there were also a series of
decisions made by lenin and stalin
to kill many of the people in the center
left and marginalize them
to and also not to associate with the
more
quote unquote like uh like amenable
communists
in order to make sure that their pure
strain of bolshevism
was the only thing and the reason i like
that is because it comes back to a point
i made it
earlier it's all about intentionality
which is that you actually
can will something into existence yes
even if people don't want it
that was the craziest thing like that
nobody wanted this yeah but it still
ruled for
half a century well more actually i mean
almost you know that's seven
years to think that there could have
been a history
of uh the soviet union
that was dramatically different than uh
leninism stalinism
that was completely different like
almost would be the american story yeah
oh easily i mean there's a world where
and i don't have all the characters
there's like karensky and then there was
like
uh whoever lenin's number two stalin's
chief rival and even
i mean look even a soviet union led by
trotsky that's a whole other world
right like literally a whole other world
and
yeah it's just i don't know i find it so
interesting i will never not be
fascinated by russia
i always will it's funny that i get to
talk to you because it's like
i read this book i forget what it's
called it won i think it won a pause
surprise
and it was like the story of i tried to
understand
russia post crimea because i i
came up amongst people who are much more
like neoconservative and they're like
[ __ ] russia
russia bad bye and i was like okay like
what do these people think
and we have this narrative of like the
fall of the soviet union and then i read
this book
from the perspective of russians who
lived through the fall and they were
like this
i was like this is terrible like
actually the introduction of capitalism
was awful
and all like the rise of all these crazy
oligarchs
that's why putin was came to power
to like restore um restore
order to the oligarchy and he still
talks to this day do you guys i mean
that's always the threat of like do you
want to return to the 90s
right do you want to return yeah and and
like but the thing is in the west
we have this like our own propaganda of
like no yeltsin was great that was the
golden age what could have been
with russia and i was like well what do
actual russians think
and so that yeah i i i'll always be
fascinated by
it and then just like to understand the
idea of feeling encircled by nato
and all that you have to understand like
russian defense
theory all the way up going back to the
tsars has always been
defense in depth in terms of having
estonia lithuania and more as like
protection of the heartland i'm not
justifying in this so nato shills like
please don't come after me
but and look estonian estonians like
nato they want to be in nato so i don't
want to minimize that i'm more just
saying like
i understand him and russia much better
having done that and we're very
incapable in america i think this is
probably because my parents are
immigrants and i've traveled a lot
of putting yourself in the mind of
people
who aren't western and haven't lived a
history
especially our lives of america is
[ __ ] awesome we're the number one
country in the world
yeah i'm like we're literally better
than you like in many ways
and they they they can't empathize with
people who have suffered
so much yeah and i just yeah it's just
so interesting to me
what about if we could talk for just a
brief moment about the human of
putin and power
you are clearly fascinated by power
do you think power changed putin
do you think power changes leaders if
you look at the
great leaders in history whether it's
lbj
fdr do you think power really changes
people like is there truth to that kind
of old
proverb it reveals i think that's what
it is
it reveals so putin was a much more deft
politician
much more amenable to the west if you
think back you know to 2001 and more
right when he came because he was still
because at that time his biggest problem
was intra-russian politics
right like it was all consolidating
power within the oligarchy
once he did that by around like 2007
there's that famous time when he spoke
out against the west at the munich
security conference i forget when it was
and that's when everybody in the
audience was like whoa and he was
talking about like nato encirclement and
like we will not be beaten back
by the west very shortly afterwards like
the georgia invasion happens
and that was like a big wake up call of
like we will not be pushed around
anymore
i mean he said before publicly like the
worst thing that ever happened was the
fall or
what did he say it was like the fall of
the soviet union was a tragedy right
yeah of course people in the west were
like what i'm like
i get it right like they were a
superpower now their
population is declining like it's like a
petrol state it sucks
like i understand um i understand like
how
somebody could feel about that i think
it revealed his character
um which is that he
i think he thinks of himself probably as
he always has since 2001
as like this benevolent almost as a
benevolent dictator he's like without me
the whole system would collapse
i'm the only guys keeping these people
and i'm the only guy keeping all these
people in check
most russians probably do support putin
because they feel like they support some
form
of functional government it's like a
check
against that which is a long you know
has a long history
within russia too so i don't know if it
changed him i think it just revealed him
um because it's not like he i mean he
has a bill you know navalny has put that
like billion dollar palace and all that
i don't know sometimes i feel like putin
does that for show
he doesn't seem like somebody who
indulges in all that stuff or maybe we
just don't see it like i don't know well
i don't
i it's very difficult for me to
understand i've been hanging out thanks
to clubhouse
a lot of i've gotten to learn a lot
about the
navalny folks and it's been very
educational
made me ask a lot of important questions
about what
um you know question a lot of my
assumptions about what i do and don't
know
but i'll just say that
i do believe you know there's a lot of
the navalny folks say that putin is
incompetent
and there's a is a bad uh executive like
is bad at
basically running government but to me
why do russians not think that right
well they
probably would probably press right yeah
they will say the control there
there is a strong either control or
pressure on the press
but i think there is a legitimate
support and love of putin in russia
that is not grounded in just
misinformation and uh propaganda there's
there's legitimacy there
mostly i try to remain apolitical and
actually
genuinely remain up apolitical i am
legitimately not interested
in the politics of russia of today
i feel i have some responsibility and
i'll take it that responsibility on as i
need to but
my fascination as it is perhaps with you
in part is
in the historical figure of putin i know
he's currently president
but i'm almost looking like as if i was
a kid in 30 years from now reading about
him
studying the the human being
the the games of power that are played
that got him to
gain power to maintain power what that
says about
his human nature the the nature of
the bureaucracy that's around him the
nature of russia the people
all those kinds of things as opposed to
the politics and the manipulation and
the corruption and the
control of the media that results in
misinformation
you know those those are the bickering
of the day just like we're saying
what will actually be remembered about
this moment in history totally he's a
transformational figure in russian
history really like the bridge between
the fall of the soviet union and the
chaos of yeltsin
that will be how he's remembered the
only question is what comes
next and what he wants to come next
that's i'm always fat i'm like
he's getting up how old is he 60
something yeah 60 so he would be
i think he would be 80 so with the with
the change of the
constitution he cannot be president
until uh
uh 2034 i think it is
so he would be like 80 something and he
would be in power for over 30 years
which is longer than stalin
so but he's still he still seems to be
he seems fit i think he's gonna be
around for a long time but this is a
fascinating question that you ask which
is like
what does he want i don't know yeah
that's the question i don't i uh
and this is where i think given all of
his behavior and more
i don't know if it's about money i don't
know if it's about enriching himself
obviously he did to the tune of billions
and billions and billions of dollars
but i think he probably he's as close to
like an actual
russian nationalist like at the top who
really does believe
in russia as its rightful superpower
everything he does seems to stem
from that opposition to nato intro to
syria like wanting to play
a large role in uh affairs
deeply distrustful and yet coveting
of the european powers like look i could
describe
every czar you know in those same
language like every czar falls into the
exact same category
yeah and i mean it makes me wonder
looking at some of the
biggest leaders in human history to ask
the question of
what was the motivation what was the
motivation for even just the
revolutionaries like lennon trotsky
and stalin what was the motivation
because it sure as hell seems
like the motivation was at least in part
the driven by the idea
by ideas not self interest of like power
for lenin it was i think he was a true
believer and an
actual narcissist who thought he was the
only one who could do it stalin i do
think just wanted power
and realized well i don't know look he
wrote very passionately when he was
young
and he was he really believed in
communism in the beginning he did
i i i always what i'm always fascinated
is i'm like
around 1920 what happened right
post-revolution
you crushed the whites now it's all
about consolidation
that's where the games really begin yeah
i mean i'm like i don't think that was
about communism
yeah yeah yeah
yeah maybe it became a useful propaganda
tool but it still
seemed like he believed in it uh whether
it was of course
this the question i mean this is the
problem with uh conspiracy theories for
me
and this is legitimate criticism towards
me about conspiracy theories which is uh
you know just because you're not like
this doesn't mean others aren't like
this so like i can't believe that
somebody'd be
like deeply two-faced oh i've met them
you're welcome to washington
but like i think that i would be able to
detect
like no people are good well this
my question is i've seen it i mean well
so this difference this
just two-face like uh there's
different levels of two-face like what i
mean is to be
killing people and uh
it's like house of cards style right and
and still present a front like you're
you're like you're not killing people i
don't know
if i guess it's possible but i just
don't see that at scale
uh like there's a lot of people like
that and i don't i have trouble
imagining
um some you know that's such a
compelling narrative
that people like to say like people
that's the conspiratorial mindset i
think that skepticism was really
powerful and important to have because
it's true a lot of powerful people abuse
their power but saying that a bottle
i feel like people over assume that
it's like i see that with the use of
steroids often in sports
people seem to make that claim about
like everybody who's successful
and i want to be very i don't know
something about me wants to be cautious
because
i want to give people a chance being
purely cynical isn't helpful people say
that's about me he's always saying this
to do this
yeah but at the same time being naively
optimistic about everything is also
kind of productive because people are
going to [ __ ] you over
and more importantly that doesn't bother
me more importantly you're not gonna be
able to reason about
how to create systems that are going to
be robust to corruption to uh
malevolent uh like parties so
so in order to create you have to have a
healthy balance of both i suppose
especially if you want to actually
engineer things that that that work in
this world that has evil in it
right i can't believe there's a book of
hitler on the desk
um we've mentioned a lot of books
throughout this conversation
i wonder and this makes me really
curious to
explore in a lot of depth
the kind of books that you're interested
in i think you mentioned in your show
that you uh you provide recommendations
yes
i do in the form of spoken word
can you be on what we've already
recommended mention
books whether it is historical
uh non-fiction or whether it's more like
philosophical or even fiction that had a
big impact on your life
so is there a few that you can mention
sure i already talked about the johnson
book so i'll leave that alone robert a
carro
he's still alive thank god he's
finishing the last book
uh i hope he makes it so that those
johnson books
second but can i ask you a question
about those books yes what the
hell do you fit into so many pages
everything man
let me tell you this so i'll just give
it an anecdote this is why i love these
books
the beginning the first book is about
lyndon johnson yes
his life to when he gets elected to
congress
the book begins with a history of texas
and its weather patterns and then of his
great
great grandfather moving to texas yes
then the story of that about a hundred
or so pages in you get to
lyndon johnson yes that's that's how you
do it
okay which is you like a tolstoy this is
the thing it's not a biography it's a
story of the times
that's a great biography so another one
this isn't part of my list so don't
[Laughter]
is all right grant off the record ron
chernow ron chernow's grant it's a
thousand pages
and the reason i tell everybody to read
it is it's not just the story of grant
it is the story of pre-civil war america
the mexican-american war
the civil war and reconstruction all
told in the life of one person who was
involved in all three
most people don't know anything about
the mexican-american war it's
fascinating
most people don't know anything about
reconstruction now more so because
people are talking it's a hot topic now
i've been reading about it for years
that is another thing people
need to learn a lot more about in terms
of non-history books
the book that probably had the most
impact on me which is also
a historical nonfiction is i
am obsessed with antarctic exploration
and it all began with a book called
shackleton's incredible journey which is
the
collection of diaries of everybody who
was on shackleton's journey for those
who don't know
shackleton was the last explorer
of the heroic age of antarctic
exploration
he led a ship called the endurance
which froze in the ice um off the coast
of antarctica
in 1914 and
they didn't have radios or the last
exploration a last one without the age
of radio
and he happens to freeze in the ice and
then
the ship collapses after a year frozen
in the ice
and this man leads his entire crew
from that ship onto the ice with a team
of dogs
survives out on the ice for another year
with three little lifeboats and is able
to get
all of his men every single one of them
alive to an island
hundreds of miles away called elephant
island and when they got
there he had to leave everybody behind
except for six people
and him and two other guys i'm
forgetting their names
navigated by the stars 800 miles through
the drake passage with seas
of hundreds of feet to prince i think
it's called prince george's island
and then when they got to prince
george's island they landed on the wrong
side
and they had to hike from one side to
the other
to go and meet the whalers and every
single one of those things was supposed
to be impossible
nobody was ever nobody was ever supposed
to hike that island it wasn't done again
until like the 1980s
with professional equipment he did it
after two years of starvation
nobody was ever supposed to make it from
elephant island to prince the guy they
had to hold him steady his legs
so that he could chart the stars and if
they miss this island
they're into open sea they're dead and
then before that
how do you survive for a year on the ice
yeah on seals
and before that he kept his crew
from depression frozen one year in the
ice
it's just an amazing story and it made
me obsessed
with antarctic exploration so i've read
like 15 books on what the hell is it
about the human spirit that's amazing
that's the thing about antarctica is it
brings it out of you so for example i
read another one
recently called mawson's will douglas
mawson he was an australian he was on
the or one of the first
shackled uh frost robert frost
expeditions he leads an expedition down
to the south
him and a partner they're leading
uh explorations 1908 something like that
they're going around
antarctica with dog teams
and one of the what happens is they keep
going over these
snow bridges where there's a crevice but
it's covered in snow
and so the one of the the lead driver
the dogs go over and they plummet and
that sled
takes with it so the guy survives but
that sled takes
all their food half the dogs their
stove the camping tent
the tent specifically designed for the
snow everything
and they're hundreds of miles away from
base camp
he and this guy have to make it back
there in time
before the ship comes to come get them
on an agreed-upon date
and he makes it but the guy he was with
he dies
and it's a crazy story they have first
of all they have to eat the dogs the a
really creepy part of antarctic
exploration is everyone ends up eating
dogs
at different points yeah um and part of
the theory which is so crazy is that
the guy he was with was dying because
they were eating dog liver and dog liver
has a lot of vitamin e
which if you eat too much of it can give
you like a poisoning
and so uh mawson by trying to help his
friend was giving him more of
all the things that kills you i know
it's dog liver
so his friend ends up dying have a
horrific heart attack
all of that mauson crawls back hundreds
of miles away
makes it back to base camp hours after
the ship leaves
and two guys or a couple of guys stayed
behind for him
and he basically has to recuperate for
like six months before he can even walk
again
but it's like you're saying about the
human spirit it's like antarctica
brings that out of people or amundsen
the guy who made it to the south pole
robert amundsen oh my god like this guy
trained his whole life in the ice
from norway to make it to the south pole
and he beat robert frost the the british
guy with all this money
and all these i could go on this forever
i'm sorry i'm obsessed with it
well first of all i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna take this part of the podcast
i'm going to set it to music yeah i'm
going to listen to it because i've been
whining and bitching about uh running 48
miles with goggins this next weekend
and this is going to be so easy i'm just
going to listen to this over and over in
my head you're going to be
elon's obsessed with shackleton he talks
about him all the time he uses
i was going to ask you about that yeah
as an example of
that is a as an example of what mars
colonization
would be like he's right no that
antarctica is as close
to you can simulate that um
the antarctic goes as close to what you
could simulate what it would get that
that nat geo series on mars i'm not sure
if you watched it
it's incredible elon's actually in it um
and it kind of and it's like
they get there everything goes wrong
somebody dies
like it's horrible it they can't find
any water
it's not working so what what is it is
it like simulating the experience of
what it'd be like
so it's like a docu-series where the
fictionalized part
is the like astronauts on mars but then
they're interviewing people like elon
musk and others who are the ones who
like
paved the way to get to mars this is a
really interesting concept
i think it's on netflix and yeah i agree
with him 100
which is that the first guys to make
like for example robert frost who
uh uh went to australia sorry
to antarctica the british explorer who
was beaten to the south pole three weeks
by robert amundsen he died on the way
back and the reason why is because he
wasn't well prepared he was arrogant
he didn't have the proper amounts of
supplies
his team had terrible morale antarctica
is a brutal place if you [ __ ] up
one time you die and it's like you and
this is what you read a lot about which
is
the reason why such heroic characters
like shackleton shine
is a lot of people died like there were
some people who got frozen in the eye
i mean man this again also came to the
north exploration
so i read a lot about like the
exploration of the north pole
and same thing these unextraordinary men
take people out into the ice and get
frozen out there for
years and [ __ ] goes so bad they end up
eating each other
they all die there's a famous one i'm
forgetting his name the british
franklin expedition where they went
searching for them for like 20 years
and they eventually came across a group
of inuit who were like oh yeah we saw
some weird white men here like 15 years
ago
and they find their bones and there's
like saw marks which show that they were
eating each other
so history remembers the ones who didn't
eat each other yeah
we were well yeah we remember the ones
who made it but there
are uh and that would be the story of
mars
that will be the story of ours so but
and nevertheless that's the interesting
thing
about antarctica nevertheless
something about human nature drives us
to
explore it yes that and that seems to be
like you know a lot of people have this
kind of
to me frustrating conversations like
well
earth is great man why do we need to
colonize mars you just don't get it
it i don't know i mean i don't know it's
the same people that say like
why are you running like why are you
running a marathon
what are you running from man yeah i
don't know
it's pushing the limits of the uh of the
human mind of the
of what's possible it's like mallory
because it's there yeah it's simple and
that
and that somehow actually the result of
that
if you want to be pragmatic about it
there's something about pushing that
limit
that has side effects that you don't
expect that will create a better world
back home for the people
not necessarily on earth but like just
in general
it raises the quality of life for
everybody even though
the initial endeavor doesn't make any
sense the very fact of pushing
the limits of what's possible
then has side effects of benefiting
everybody
and it's difficult to predict ahead of
time or what those benefits will be
same with colonizing mars it's unclear
what the benefits will be for earth or
in general
what's struggling get from the moon what
did we get from apollo
right technically and there were a lot
of socialists at the time making this
argument they're like
all this money going you know what we
went to the [ __ ] moon
in 1969 that was amazing the greatest
feat in human history period what did we
learn from it
we learned and we learned about
interstellar or interplanetary travel
we learned that we could do something
off of
a device less powerful than the computer
in my pocket yeah like the
the amount of potential locked within my
pocket and your pocket
i mean this is if you were to define my
politics in one way it's
greatness like national a quest for
national
greatness there is no greatness without
fulfilling
the ultimate calling of the human spirit
which is more
it's not enough and why should it be
yeah it wasn't enough
you know our ancestors could have been
content
to sit well actually many of them were
were content to sit
and say these berries will be here for a
long time and they got eaten
and they died and it's the ones who got
out
and went to the next place in the next
place and went across the siberian land
bridge
and went across more and it just did
extraordinary things the craziest ones
we are their offspring and we fail them
if we don't
go into space that's how i would put it
you should run for president i'm just
broke space man i love face
no you're pro doing difficult things and
pushing
uh exploring the world in all of its
forms i hope that kind of spirit
permeates politics too that same kind of
uh
can it well it can and i hope so
i don't know if you want to stay on it
but i think that was book number one
or two [ __ ] yeah okay all right all
right um is there
well this one is a second this actually
is a corollary to that which is sapiens
and i know that's a very normal
normie answer yeah um one of the best
selling but i think there's a reason for
that yeah you've all know harari
of course okay look yes he didn't do any
new research
i get that all he did was aggregate i'm
sure he's very controversial in the
scientific community
but guess what he wrote a great book
it's a very
easy to read general explanation of the
rise of human
history and it helps challenge a lot of
preconceptions are we special
are we an accident are we more like a
parasite or are we not
what is there a destiny to all of us i
don't know
you know if anything it's like what i
just described which is more
move move out um the evolution of money
like i know he gets a lot of hate but i
think that he writes it
so clearly and well that for your
average person to be able to read that
you will come away
with a more clear understanding of the
human race
than before and i think that that's why
it's worth it i agree with you 100
i uh i'm ashamed to i usually don't
bring up sapiens because it's like
yeah it's like everybody's uncle has
read it but it's that's a good thing
yeah it is one of the i think you'll be
remembered as one of the great books of
this particular era
and yeah because it's it's so clearly
it's like the
selfish gene with darkest i mean it just
aggregates so many ideas together and
puts language to it that's
makes it very useful to talk about so it
is one of the great books
100 um another one is definitely born to
run
for the same reason by christopher
mcdougall which is that i'm just gonna
listen to this whole podcast next week
you have to well you should because it
you are inheriting
our most basic skill which is running
and
reimagining human history or reimagining
like what we were as opposed to what we
are is very useful because it helps you
understand how to tap into primal
aspects of your brain which just
drive you and the reason i love
mcdougall's writing is because
i love anybody who writes like this
malcolm gladwell um who else
michael lewis people who find characters
to tell a bigger story michael lewis
finds characters to tell us the story of
the financial crisis um
you know malcolm gladwell writes finds
characters to tell us the story of
learning new skills and outliers and
diff you know whatever his latest book
is
i forget what it's called and but
mcdougall
tells the vignettes and a tiny story of
a single person
in the history of running and like how
it's
baked into your dna and i think there
was just something very useful
to that for me for being like i don't
need to go to the gym or like
i'm not saying you should still go to
the gym i'll be clear i'm saying like in
order to fulfill like
who you are you can actually tap into
something that's
the most basic um i i don't know i'm
sure if you listen to the david cho
episode with joe rogan um you know i
mean oh where he's
the animal yeah with the baboon when he
goes and
there's something to that man there's
something to that which is like
they are living the way that we were
supposed to
yeah we're not suppo well i don't want
to put a normal judgment on it they're
living the way
that we used to yeah there's something
feels very honest somehow
to to our true nature there's a guy i
follow on instagram
i've come from paul saladino carnivore
md
yeah he just went over there to the
hotza um to live with them
and i was watching his stuff just like i
was like man
there's there's something in you that
wants to go yeah like
i'm like i want to do that yeah i
wouldn't be very good at it but like i
want to
i'm so glad that somebody who thinks
deeply about politics
is so fascinating with exploration and
with
the very basic nature
like human nature nature of our
existence i love that
there's something in you and still
you're stuck in dc
for now for now speaking of which
the you are from texas yes what do you
make
of the future of texas politically
culturally
uh economically i am in part
moving well i'm moving to austin
congrats
but i'm also doing the eric weinstein
advice which is like
dude you're not married you don't have
kids everywhere there's no such thing as
moving what what are you moving you're
like
you're like like your three suits and
some
shirts and underwear what exactly is the
move and tail
so i have nothing so i'm basically you
know
it's very just remain mobile but
there's a promise there's a hope to uh
austin
outside of i mean my uh outside of just
like friendships i have no it's a very
different culture that joe rogan is
creating i'm
mostly interested in the what the next
silicon valley will be with the next
hub of technological innovation
and there's a promise uh maybe a dream
for austin being that next place that's
very possible
doesn't have this the baggage of uh
some of the political things maybe
some of the sort of um things that hold
back
the beauty of that makes capitalism that
makes
innovation so powerful which is like
meritocracy which is excellence
uh diversity is exceptionally important
but not
uh it should not be the only priority it
has to be something that
uh it coexists with a like
insatiable drive towards excellence
and uh it seems like texas is a nice
place like having a
austin which is like a kind of uh this
weird i hope it stays weird man i love
weird people
know about that but we can get it but
as this uh hope is
it remains this weird place of brilliant
innovation
amidst the uh a state that's like more
conservative so like there's a nice
balance of everything
what are your thoughts about the future
of texas i think it's so fascinating to
me
because i never thought i would want to
move back
but now i'm beginning to be convinced
so you have that joe i'm going to say
this
i'm being honest and many texans will
hate me for this texas was not a place
that was kind to me quote unquote and
this is because of my
own parent look i was raised in college
station texas which is a town of 50 000
it's a university town it exists only
for the university
so it was a very str i did not get the
full texas experiences purely speaking
from a college station experience
but growing up first
you know first generation or i forget
what it is whatever i'm the first
american i was born and raised in
college station
my parents are from india being raised
in a town where the dominant culture was
predominantly like
white evangelical christian was hard
like he was just difficult
and i think of it
in the beginning i would say like ages
like zero to like eight
it was like cultural ignorance as in
like they just don't know how to
interact with you
um and there was a level of always there
was like the evangelical kind of
antipathy
towards like you being not christian you
know my parents are hindu like that's
how i was raised
and so like there was that but 9 11 was
very difficult
like 9 11 happened when i was in third
fourth grade and that changed everything
man
like i mean our temple had to like print
out t-shirts
and i'm not saying this is a sob story
to be clear i've still actually
largely from my adult life identified on
the political right so don't take this
as some like
you know race manifesto i'm just telling
it like this is what happened
which is that like we had
it was just hard to be brown frankly and
to have some of the fallout from 911
and during iraq and the reason i am
political
is because i realize in myself i have a
strong rebellious nature against
systems and structures of power and the
first people i ever rebelled against
were all the people telling me to shut
up
and not question the iraq war so the
reason i am in politics
is because i hated george w bush
with a passion and i hated the war and i
was so again my entire background is
largely a national security for this
reason which is
i was obsessed with the idea of like how
do we get people
who are not gonna get us into these
quagmire situations
in positions of power that's how i
became fascinated by power in the first
place
was all a question of how do this happen
like
how did this catastrophe happen i
realized it's not as bad as like you
know previous conflicts but this one was
mine
and to see how it changed our domestic
politics forever
and so that was my rebellion but
it's funny because i identified as a
left on the left when i was growing up
up until i was 18 i had also a funny
two-year stint this is where everything
kind of changed for me when i was 16
actually
i moved to qatar to doha qatar because
my dad
was a dean or associate dean of texas a
m university
at doha so my last two years of high
school were at this
i went from this small town in texas and
i love my parents because
they could recognize that i had within
me that i was not a small town kid
so they took me out of this country
every chance they got i
traveled everywhere and constantly let
me go and so i was
i went from school in college station to
like this ritzy
private school american school best
thing that ever happened to me
because first of all it got me out of
college station
second at that time i had this annoying
streak
of i wouldn't call it being anti-america
but you don't appreciate america
let me tell everybody out there
listening leave for a while
you will miss it so much yes
you do not know what it is like to not
have freedom of speech
until you don't have it yeah and i was
going to i was going
to high school with these guys in the
qatari royal family
and all i wanted to do was speak out how
they were pieces of [ __ ] for the way
that they treated
indian citizens in the country who are
basically used as slave labor
and i could not say one word because i
knew i would be deported and i knew my
dad would lose his job
and my mom will lose her job and we
would be forced out of the country
you don't know what it's like to live
like that or to be in a society where
like you know
you have like a high school girlfriend
or something and you can't even touch
in public or you're lectured for public
decency
like i listen i've lived under a gulf
monarchy now
and i have that turned me into the most
pro-america guy
ever like i came back so like
america like that's i still am frankly
because of that experience
living living abroad like that will do
it to you live in a non-democracy
you haven't even in europe i would say
you guys aren't living as free as we are
here it's
awesome you're ultimately another human
being than the one who left texas
yeah so i mean have you actually
considered moving to texas and broadly
just outside your own story
what do you think is the future of texas
what is the future of austin yes
there's so much transformation seemingly
happening now related to silicon valley
living in california
which is that since i left it's changed
dramatically which is that it used to be
like this conservative state where
the main money to be made was oil and
everybody knew that petro
it was a petro state houston all of that
austin was always weird but it was more
of a music town and a university town it
was not a tech town
but in the 10 years or so since i left
i have begun to realize i'm like well
the texas i grew up in
is over it is not a deep red state
in any sense in any sense of the term
the number one
u-haul route in the country pre-pandemic
already was san francisco to austin
okay so like you have this massive
influx of people from california
and new york and the state the
composition of it
is changed dramatically the
intracomposition
and the outro yeah so the
intracomposition it's become way more
urban it's from when i grew when i grew
up texas was a much more rural state
its politics were much more static it
looked much more like rick perry like
that
he was a very accurate representation
yes of who we were
now i don't think that that's the case
texas is now
a dynamic economy not just 100 reliant
on oil
because of its kind of like i would call
it like regulatory arbitrage relative to
california and new york
offers a large incentive to people who
are more
i wouldn't say culturally liberal but
they're not necessarily like culturally
conservative like the people who i grew
up with
that's changed the whole state's
politics beto came two points away from
beating ted cruz
i'm not saying the state's gonna go blue
i think the republican party will just
change
and we'll have to readjust but the
re-urbanization of texas
has made it uh i'll put it in this way
much more
uh much much more attractive to me
than the place that i grew up and from
my perspective
uh well first of all i love uh some of
the
the cowboy things that texas stands for
but for more practically from my
perspective the injection of the
uh tech innovation right that's moving
to
texas has made it very exciting
to me it seems like outside of all that
maybe you can speak to the weird in
austin
it seems like i i know that
joe rogan is uh a rich
sort of uh almost like mainstream at
this point
right but he's also attracting a lot of
weirdos and so is elon
and a lot of those weirdos are my
friends and though they're like like
michael malus
like those weirdos and it's like
i have a hope for austin that all kinds
of different flavors of weirdos will get
injected
it's possible you know i i actually
think the most significant thing that
happened
were at tesla moving there yeah the
reason why is
i love joe obviously but like he can
only attract x amount of people
yeah elon actually employs thousands of
people
and then you also oracle oracle's
decision to move to austin
is just as important because those
two men larry was ellison right yeah
elson
and uh elon they actually employ tens of
thousands of people collectively
that can change the nature of the city
yeah so
you combine that with joe bringing this
entire new entertainment complex
with the bodies of people who will
appreciate
said entertainment complex spend money
on the entertainment
exactly you just remade the entire city
yeah and and that's
that's why i'm fascinated and obviously
there's network effects which is
now that all those people are down there
i mean if i were elon musk i would
donate a [ __ ] ton of money to the
university of texas and i would turn it
into my stanford
for silicon valley let's introduce some
competition
and let ut austin hire the best software
developers engineers professors and more
and turn texas into a true like austin
revolving door hub where people come to
ut austin
to get an internship at tesla and then
become an executive there
and then create their own company in
their own garage
in austin which is the next facebook
twitter that's how it happens
this is why i'm much more skeptical of
miami there's a whole like tech
miami crew i'm like yeah like there's no
university
it's very inorganic um look i think
miami is awesome
i just like i don't know if the same
building blocks are there and also
no multi-billion dollar companies which
employ
thousands of people are coming there
that's the ingredient
it's not just joe rogan it's not just
even elon musk if he's still operated in
california
it's all the people he employs i think
that is
where i think texas is going to
dramatically change within the next 10
years
alternative to our it's already become a
more urbanized
state that's moved away from oil and gas
um
in terms of like its emphasis not
necessarily in terms of its real
economics
and 10 years from now i don't think it
will be necessarily the name
prop like of the of the town the only
question to me
is how that manifests politically
because it's very possible though
because a lot of these workers
themselves are california culturally
liberal
you could see a gavin newsome type
person getting elected
governor of texas yeah or like the mayor
of austin i mean look mayor boston is
already a democrat right like
i mean uh joe has his own problems with
austin it's funny i remember him
leaving la and i'm like well we've been
to austin
it ain't you know it's not everything
it's cracked up to me you know
necessarily
but no matter what you know a new place
allows the possibility for new ideas
uh even if they're somehow left-leaning
and all those kinds of things i do think
the only two things missing
from austin and texas are two dudes in a
suit
that sometimes have a podcast talk a
bunch of nonsense and a mic
so let's let's bring the best suit game
to texas i hope you do
make it to texas uh at some point thanks
so much for talking today
thanks for listening to this
conversation with sagar sagaranjeti and
thank you to our sponsors
jordan harbinger show grammarly grammar
assistant
eight sleep self cooling bed and magic
spoon low carb cereal
click the sponsor links to get a
discount and to support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from martin luther king jr
about the idea that what is just and
what is legal
and not always the same thing he said
never forget that what hitler did in
germany
was legal thank you for listening and
hope to see you
next time
you